You know,
uh,
you know,
it's funny.
I'll tell you later.
Tell me now.
Three,
two,
one.
What's funny,
uh,
I was going to tell you a funny story
about your address,
but it wouldn't be,
it wouldn't be funny for you.
We'll talk later about that.
You and I,
we share African ancestry.
Yeah,
yeah.
I was shocked.
Yeah.
I'm one point six percent.
Oh really?
See,
I have more,
uh,
I have more credentialed in math
departments.
Your two percent,
right?
Yeah.
No,
and it's funny because,
you know,
you sort of have your,
the story in your family,
kind of like where he came from and
everything mates.
And I always knew I was 25 percent,
you know,
Italian.
Uh,
and I knew that my family came from
Sicily.
In fact,
uh,
the,
the Rainelle is that came from Sicily
all seemed to become kind of established
in the,
in the produce world.
Uh,
my dad was brought up in the south side
of Chicago.
I'm 44 years old.
Okay.
So think about that for a minute.
My Dad was brought up in south side of
Chicago and he was raised by his
grandfather who was Sicilian,
had come from Sicily,
his grandfather delivered produce with a
horse and cart whoa in Chicago,
so
to have lived through that,
like to be brought up in a house where a
guy like leaves in the morning and a
horse and cart to deliver,
produce an end to be alive,
like to fight in world war two to be
through the atomic era,
the advent of the Internet.
Right.
But I always knew that we had Sicilians
when I did the genetic test,
what some of those.
At some point in time,
one of those Sicilians must have shot
southward and crossed the Mediterranean
and lightheaded hookup down there.
Something.
Well,
that was the history of Sicily in the
first place.
Yeah.
Cecily just being Sicilian in the first
place.
There was so many people that were a
impregnated by the doors and by various
people of West Africa and North Africa.
Yeah.
I should've probably like,
always assumed,
but it just,
I hadn't thought about it.
Um,
another thing I was reading about this
stuff.
And you might know more about it than I
do,
is that when you do those tests,
there's missing parts,
you know,
it does it like it captures what's
there.
But there's could be a lot there that's
not captured just in the way that
chromosomes are inherited and passed
down.
Like it's,
it's an incomplete picture.
Right.
There can be influences.
There could,
there could be in your.
It doesn't create a full picture of your
lineage.
There could be lineages that are there
that aren't represented in your
particular makeup.
How so?
Like what do you mean?
He know?
I hate to right off the bat,
get into south that I can't speak about
any level of expertise.
I was just reading a piece and the piece
I was reading to do it was kind of a
dissection of like what happened with
Elizabeth Warren when she claimed we've
been going off about that on the podcast
and I'm like 100 times more African than
she is native American.
Yeah.
Well that's what I found.
I'm 10 times more or whatever.
But there was a piece about.
It was,
it was a piece in the times explaining
like how to make sense of now that
everyone's doing these tasks,
like how to think about,
make sense,
these tests,
but,
but my understanding of it is that you
could have a lot of ancestry that isn't
captured in your genetic code and the
way that would be detected through the
testing.
Meaning there could be ancestors it for
what?
[inaudible] you're inheriting half,
you know,
your Harrington chromosomes from each
parent in somehow you could have.
It could be an incomplete picture.
You could have ancestors that had come
from other,
you know,
whatever.
These,
these tests break out the world and do a
100 or some odd regions or zones that
there could be people from those zones
who were in your lineage that are not
captured in your personal,
that are not captured in your genetic
code.
That's so bizarre.
You would think it would all be in
there.
So that's just a,
an incomplete measuring tool.
Is that what it is or is it just
actually not in there?
I don't know.
I'm going to have to have a dude on.
Yeah,
I'll listen.
You need to understands it and as I say,
I feel like I'm off on a bad start here,
man.
I'm much a neanderthal.
Didn't say less than normal.
Really less than average.
The,
uh,
the number it said it gives you what you
did.
Twenty three and me,
right?
Yeah,
I can't remember.
I just remember it was less than average
and you know,
and those things like our refined by how
many people do,
um,
you know,
but it was less than average,
which bummed me out,
but I'm like,
his hair is like a 13 year old Norwegian
girl,
you know what I mean?
So it's surprise,
shocking,
didn't surprise me too much.
Uh,
I was wishing to have a little more of
that floating around in me.
It's a bizarre heritage,
you know,
the idea that there was a different type
of human that bread with Homo sapiens
and that there's little bits and pieces
of it floating around and people.
Yeah,
people discuss them.
People discuss,
I'll say an argument the other day where
they see a neanderthal or neanderthal
and everyone grows up saying
neanderthal.
It's one of those things you're supposed
to switch once you realize how you're
supposed to do it,
right.
Neanderthal,
but I just can't get comfortable with
it.
I go back and forth.
There's a lot of words that like that
were.
I know you're supposed to do it,
but I can't get comfortable with it
because I feel like it makes you sound
pretentious.
It's like rolling your r's and certain
Spanish words,
but we had this idea that the.
We had this idea,
the neanderthals as unsuccessful.
Right,
right.
They are these brutish thugs that died
out,
but they had a 600,000
year run in Europe alone.
600,000
years longer run than Homo sapiens have
actually existed.
Yeah.
So whatever.
I don't know that we're going to hit
like,
I don't know that we're going to match
up and have that run.
Well,
we'll probably have a 23 and
me for whatever the fuck is after us.
They look somebody back then fuck the
human.
Like,
oh,
one of those crazy warmonger Mexican
rapists,
thieving humans died out.
It turns out they didn't totally die
out.
Overrun with emotions and lies and
someone,
someone of a superior race infiltrated
the humans and banged one of them.
Yeah,
it's,
it's funny to look at that,
that understanding of those,
that understanding of those people.
I'm an end to have the site to picture
in your mind's eye,
even though you can't picture it,
like what was look like when they were
hooking up.
Someone are,
you know,
like anatomically,
behaviorally modern humans were hooking
up with neanderthals was that was.
How is it perceived by their peers?
I bet the people that we think of as
people back then,
like,
you know George,
the animal steele is no George.
The animal steel is a very famous
progress or from back in the day,
and I thought you were gonna.
Say It was a paleontologist or
anthropologists Rasler just arrest pro
wrestler.
Very famous guy who could be a fucking
cave man.
Like legitimately could be a cave man.
See if you,
uh,
you got a good image of him.
Now,
this is what I think when I think of
people now give me a full body.
One day you go,
oh,
when I think of people he's hanging
onto,
so homo sapiens,
Homo sapiens from,
you know,
200,000
years ago,
I think at George the animal steele.
I think there were something like that.
So the idea of George fucking a
neanderthal chick,
not that far off.
I think our idea is that like Dan rather
would be out there banging some monkey
lady.
I just don't think.
I don't think that's the case.
Like look at George's body.
Jesus fucking Christ.
He's got the hairiest shoulders I've
ever seen in a man.
She's still alive.
I do not know.
I don't believe he is.
I hope he's not listening right now.
I don't believe he is a,
he's a legend.
Legend in the world with the pro
wrestling.
So it's going to take more notes to hurt
his feelings.
That guy don't give a fuck.
He's a legend.
But uh,
when I was in a kid in high school,
oh,
he's,
he's olds.
Fuck yeah,
he's a pro.
Well those guys,
they all.
That's a hard way to make a at that.
At Age 79,
he had a good run.
Yeah.
That's a good run for,
for those guys.
That's a fucking hard way to make a
living.
But have we were talking about,
uh,
the,
the idea of neanderthals is like having
a Ca,
a confrontational hunting style?
No,
I don't think we have because when,
when,
when anthropologists look at the,
the skeletal remains of neanderthals,
they see this sort of suite of this
pattern of injuries on them and a
researcher is looking at the types of
fractures that they have on their bones
in where the fractures occurred and the
breaks and cracks
and they're scholes.
He was looking at all this and wound up
working with a doctor who had a lot of
exposure to rodeo riders,
bull riders and the doctor was,
was observing the way in which that
suite of injuries was very familiar to
him from rodeo riders,
the types of breaks and the location of
brakes.
And this guy has this idea that they had
a,
like a very confrontational hunting
style that they're mixing it up with big
animals.
And another thing they found is that
when you're looking at skeletal remains
from early people,
you still see that separation in the
saxes right,
that,
that the males would suffer injuries at
with a greater prevalence than females.
But with the neanderthals,
it seems like they didn't have the sort
of like duplicity of roles.
So many of the females,
the females have the same prevalence of,
of these types of injuries.
Whoa.
And so maybe they didn't have that,
the,
they didn't share that division of labor
where the females as large as the males.
Yeah.
I don't know the answer to that.
So we know that they had stone tools,
right?
The crude stone tools.
Yeah.
But we don't know whether or not they
had anything that could launch them.
Like they didn't have to.
They would,
do,
we know if they had spears,
I don't believe that they've found they
had adult adult and I don't know if they
were hafting materials,
but they were doing,
they were doing art.
Um,
and I think there's a little bit of a
debate about whether they're doing
representational art,
but they were doing art.
They were doing,
they were probably making jewelry and is
like,
these are all things that as,
as we kind of like wake up to what these
people really like and it paints like a
more complicated picture.
There's even this theory and I don't
know if this held any water,
how long it was fashionable for,
but you had this really long history of
it was extremely long history of
hundreds of thousands of years in the
Andrew Fall,
you know,
occupation in Europe and then it seemed
to be the.
I remember someone putting forth this
idea that it seemed to be that there was
this flourishing of advancement that was
contemporaneous with the arrival of our
own ancestors in Europe is though,
uh,
they were being exposed to or seeing art
and seeing jewelry and mimicking this
from these new invaders that were coming
in.
But I don't know where that idea sits
right now.
I don't know if it's been dispelled
because of other discoveries and
everything does an interesting idea that
they would then it kind of paints this
really sad picture,
right?
That they would be sort of in the
autumn,
you know,
of their existence and here's these
adorned people showing up with these
amazing tool kits and all these
abilities and kind of struggling to
start a catch up,
you know,
it'd be like the country Bumpkin,
go into the big city and.
Yeah.
Well there was also this idea,
I think up until very recently that
neanderthals were not as violent as
humans as homo sapiens.
But now there was an article that was
published just a couple of days ago that
new evidence shows that neanderthals
like internet and tall violence between
each other.
It was just as bad as homosapians.
Yeah.
And find that in evidence of
cannibalism.
Oh yeah.
There was a lot of that.
Right.
Scraping of inside of the skulls
indicative of tools.
Oh,
ad blocker got busted.
They get us every time with the fucking
ad blocker.
Yeah.
Um,
what does it say?
Humans are just as violent as
neanderthals.
Are you familiar with the writer John Mu
Allen?
No.
You'd like his stuff.
He wrote a really beautiful piece about.
He wrote a really beautiful piece about
neanderthals not long ago.
Okay.
I fucked it up.
What they're saying is that modern
humans were just as prone to violence as
neanderthals.
I don't have a problem.
I think I'm conflating this with
something else that I read about.
Inter Inter interspecies violence
neanderthal on neanderthal violence.
The other thing that's weird about them,
as they had bigger brains than us,
they had bigger brains and they would be
like five,
seven and weighed 200 pounds.
Just jacked.
Just a little gorilla thing.
You know,
it'd be great to see it.
There is a really dumb theory that was
being bounced around a few years ago.
It was really hilarious about how,
uh,
we wiped out.
We assumed that neanderthals,
because you don't have any soft tissue
samples,
we've seen that neanderthals looked
similar to humans,
but because of the very different shape
of their skull this guy had,
instead of giving them European looking
white skin,
turn them into a gorilla,
turned them into a giant muscle bound
gorilla that preyed on people.
And this was like,
I believe it was an actually is actually
was a professor.
And it seemed almost like a goof at
first.
Do you remember this champion?
We pulled this up a few times,
like killer neanderthal theory,
think you call it,
but he had drawn this thing black,
like a gorilla with like giant muscles
all over the place and these big crazy
eyes and that painting neanderthals as a
Predator of humans and that's why we
wiped them out.
Yeah.
That my limitations as
I see I,
I'll just say my limitations as an,
as an anthropologist,
I'm certainly not an anthropologist at
all.
Just a dude who's interested in it.
But one of my limitations is I'll hear
theories floated.
Okay.
And I don't follow them long enough to
see which ones have any traction.
Right.
I'll just read about them and I don't
take it as Gospel,
but I'll read about it and I'll be like,
that's interesting.
And was sort of shaped my understanding
of it.
But then I don't keep track of it.
Like I try to really follow the story of
like the peopling of the Americas.
So when it comes to the human history of
the Western Hemisphere,
I sort of follow and like ideas will get
floated and
they'll track the idea to see where it
lands in terms of scholarly consensus,
but on other stuff with neanderthals,
I'm always a sucker for a neanderthal
story,
but I don't track
what ideas that float up or just very
quickly denounced as being complete
rubbish.
Mm.
Yeah.
It's a weird one.
You know,
it takes time to.
It takes time to follow this stuff.
Go,
go to that other picture.
That's what it is them them and,
and uh,
yeah.
But look at some of his images.
Look at that image that he has on the
cover of the book.
Like those are the idea.
There's some way better ones.
There's some way better images with they
drew of a full body ones.
They had a.
is it in the article?
This was a link to your website from a
different article.
Just go,
go to that and then go to images because
there was some really bizarre fucking.
Yeah,
there it is.
Upper left hand corner.
This is what,
this guy.
Yeah.
Well,
that thing,
whatever he's got going on,
that thing is not making art.
You don't think so?
No.
He's making meat,
man.
Come on.
Yeah.
It's pretty preposterous.
But neanderthals didn't have things like
that.
Did they know what is that?
He's he morphing in neanderthal into a
gorilla that was trying to do.
Oh,
that's Ah,
a monkey gorilla.
Neanderthal.
But yeah.
But like,
whoa.
It's got it snarling with it's fucking
vegetable eating teeth.
Anyway,
it's,
it's a.
and then there's the do even know what
those Denovo eons to.
How do you say that word?
The one from Russia.
They didn't have any idea what they
looked like right now.
I don't look like so pinky bones and
shit,
you know,
have that.
That one's not that one.
I don't know him in your cookbook is
fucking fantastic.
It's really good.
Yeah.
You put a lot of God damn work into that
thing.
We started collecting images for it
years ago.
He could tell it's really good because I
didn't want it to look like I'm.
What was it boring you tell about
neanderthals now I'm out of stuff to say
about him.
Anyway.
No,
I could go on for days.
That's the problem.
Things were not quite sure about exactly
what I heard.
That's what I do for a living.
So I watch I to get back to the coupe
but real quick.
But Yo,
it's funny as a
um,
how many,
you probably don't know this,
but how many people in the wildlife
world listened to your show and get
angry about it?
Because I'm like a conduit.
I,
Joe,
that that's not how it works.
I'm like a conduit where I'm oftentimes
getting frantic text messages is though
I would be able to jump in and clarify
like how a porcupine quill works or.
Yeah.
It's really funny how many people are
here from what I can tell when you're on
a.
I know like when you're on the subject
of wildlife,
if there's marijuana in the room,
we got a real issue with antlers or for.
He should really know
who knows what antlers for other than.
Well,
there are two things,
right?
If there for fighting and sexual
selection,
right?
Yeah.
Two things that definitely makes sense.
We in like a sexual display,
we've got a bull in Utah,
this,
uh,
this year and when we were butchering
it,
one of the hind quarters had been
punctured by an antler and got infected
and when we cut into the Hindquarter,
just this bucket of pus came out.
I mean it was fucking nasty.
We thought it was pissed at first,
like someone actually puncture the
bladder.
And then we realized when we got deep
into it that there was just this giant
has and he had been asked like literally
right in the flank and it was just so
fucking nasty.
Do you find really high pressure poss
pockets in like
in animals all over his body.
He had holes in his ribs.
He had big one and his face had been
jacked in the face.
I got to seek a deer last year who had
lost his eye completely gone.
I mean like the desire ball had been
punctured and people were asking me,
well,
no wonder you got them.
But I was like,
no.
It was good.
I was facing me on his line of approach.
It didn't know where you were.
Has left perception is a left I was
facing me but yet with the cookbook,
so we started gathering pictures up for
it years ago,
um,
because I wanted to have this really
complete idea of how to process
everything.
So like the book includes everything
from how to process a bullfrog,
you know,
to a deer to pig to Mahi Mahi.
And a problem I run into when I've done
books is I never wind up needing.
I never wind up needing a pad them in
the end.
I always might have having like very
painful cuts.
Yeah.
You know,
when I did my book,
My book,
American Buffalo member,
I had to lose 100 pages,
which was hard to do when we did the
complete guide to hunting,
butchering and cooking wild game.
It came out at 700 pages.
Do you ever think of going back and
putting those 100 pages back into.
Do you think it made sense to remove it?
No.
In hindsight had to happen.
It had to happen in terms of like the
narrative stuff I've written.
That's the,
you know,
the narrative nonfiction I've written.
That's my favorite thing that I've done
and uh,
it had to happen,
but it was painful and we did,
when I did those guidebook,
the guidebook series that came in at 700
pages and my publisher was a,
my publisher was like,
you know,
you just don't really make 700 page
books.
And so that's why we wanted to do
another volume one and volume two
because I didn't want to get rid of any.
But then in doing this,
this cookbook,
the mediator fishing game cookbook is
what it's called and putting this
together.
I think early on we started to get a
little bit kind of running a little bit
wild about what was going to fit but
then caught it earlier.
But that was the first thing we did is
we started collecting the pictures
because I think a lot of times you look
at a book,
an illustrated book,
and it kind of smells like a photo
shoot.
You know what I'm saying?
Where you can tell that they get.
They sort of how they got the images.
And I didn't want to feel like that.
I wanted it to sort of feel like really
representative of so many different
places and different experiences that
are captured in here and so we just
started filming his process shots of how
to walk stuff through like everything,
you know,
how to like turn things,
how to take an animal and make it into a
variety of usable ingredients and
collecting all those took a long time
and then and then actually like
assembling it and putting,
putting it together was more systematic
once we had that underway.
But I think it's like it's cool looking.
No,
no,
no.
It's great.
Like the book in the end where it's kind
of like half could almost pass as a
coffee table book.
I agree.
Yeah.
No,
it really could.
And I think it's a really valuable
resource for people that hunt because
it's just mean he was only so many
different ways you can cook backstraps
right?
There's so many different ways you can
put ground venison into spaghetti sauce,
you know,
you're giving people such a wide variety
of things to include in your original
books as well.
A wide variety of things to,
you know,
to,
to cook and ways to cook them.
Well,
it's one of the things I really enjoyed
about your show,
you know,
um,
and still do,
but now that it's on Netflix,
I actually,
I enjoy it even more,
but they,
you do a lot of cooking on your show.
Yeah.
That's,
that's very rare in the hunting world.
You know,
you see these hunting shows,
they're very one dimensional,
right?
You see someone looking for the animal
and then they finally get it and Yay,
everybody's happy the end,
but you,
um,
you spend a great deal of time,
break it down animals and cooking a
bunch of different things,
including like marrow and shanks and
unusual preparations.
I think that's really important.
Yeah,
that's,
that's something that was,
that was always there for me growing up
and hunting,
fishing.
Very complicated.
And you do them for a bunch of reasons.
I think that people in explaining
hunting to audiences or explaining it to
people who are uninitiated,
uninformed about it,
maybe adversarial toward it.
You sort of,
you wind up grabbing these things that
you end up grabbing these things that,
um,
that you think will resonate with them.
Right?
I have a friend,
Greg Blaskiewicz,
who'd even worked on this research piece
of taking justifications for hunting and
finding test subjects who are skeptical
of hunting and explaining various
justifications to them and seeing which
ones of those that they find to be most
impactful.
So he's actually done research around
when you take this great,
like these broad spectrum of reasons
people do this,
you know,
and,
and everyone that has many of them as
part of their story,
right?
And,
and you,
you run them by people,
he sees these ones that they really
resonate and which ones kind of move the
needle and their perception of it.
And it's a little bit surprising.
There's some,
there's some surprises in there of ones
that you think would be really impactful
but in fact are not impactful at all
that people don't care about.
Like what?
Well,
population control people don't care
people.
I think that people don't.
The kind of people you're talking about
who are largely unfamiliar with it.
But they're looking at it from the
outside and they're skeptical of it.
They have a hard.
They don't buy it.
I don't think that they're afraid of
deer generally,
but people who live in high population
areas.
Like I did a Gig once in western
Massachusetts.
Well yeah,
it was in western Massachusetts and I
had a drive.
I was coming from New York and I had to
drive through the most dear infested
place I've ever been to in my life.
It was completely insane.
Like when you're driving on the highway,
you have to go 25,
30 miles an hour and things are just
jumping in front of your car every 15,
20 seconds.
It was fucking nuts,
man.
And I would.
I took the side road down to get to
wherever the Gig was and I'm just
watching these animals jumping in front
of the car,
like left and right.
And I'm like,
these people that live here,
these things are God damn nuisance.
Like if this was your everyday reality
and you ask those people,
he said,
hey,
what do you think about deer population
control?
We need to hunt to keep the population
down.
They'd be like,
fuck yeah,
you do.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
I'm sure that there are quite a lot of
people that live in some of these areas
that have a great abundance of deer that
feel that way.
But with general population,
yeah.
When he was looking at it with just
general population thing and it was full
stop to.
He didn't get.
He didn't give a lot of.
He didn't go in and give case scenarios
and examples.
Right.
It's just a question that you ask and
people.
It didn't immediately click with people.
Another thing that didn't immediately
click with people,
but it's extremely important to me is
issues around heritage and legacy.
Okay.
So meaning that,
um,
my maternal grandfather,
my paternal grandfather were hunters.
My father was a hunter.
I was brought up hunting,
um,
to anon.
Hunter.
Doesn't matter.
Your grandparents and parents could have
been involved in all kinds of bad shit.
I don't need that.
That means you need to continue doing
bad shit.
I'm one that's very obvious is people
understand,
people understand and respect the idea
of food.
Like,
uh,
your general population,
look and respect the idea of food now
tobacco,
what I was getting at about,
you mentioned that being a big element
of the show.
Uh,
it almost winds up being that it was
like I was like fortunate or lucky or
whatever that,
that,
that early in my career I started
focusing on talking about that aspect of
it.
But it wasn't something I just made up
out of because it was a huge part of
growing up where for whatever reason I
happen to be raised by a dad who was
just really interested in cooking stuff
and sharing with people,
you know.
And if he,
if you're driving down the road in June
and you see a snapping turtle laying
eggs on the side of the road,
it's come up out of a swamp and you
needed to find some sandy ground and he
finds it on the edge of a dirt road.
And there it is.
Land,
eggs on the side of the dirt road.
We were eating that turtle right?
And everything we ate,
you know,
all kinds of fish.
And we had a lot of things that other
people weren't interested in.
We could go out and bring back our dad
bullfrogs you would love if we went out
and got them.
Frogs.
We take our bows out at night using
flashlights,
which unbeknownst to me was illegal and
remains illegal in the state where I was
brought up even for frog to use
artificial light for frogs.
Yeah.
Wow.
I had no dude when I found that out
later.
No idea.
Wow.
Um,
the day that you weren't supposed to do
that,
where we would do it and we'd come in
and bring them.
And it was like a big thing,
right?
To bring her dad the frog legs and he
would cook them and he would cook and
eat anything.
And then he would do stuff where we
would catch salmon when the salmon were
running the rivers in October and he
would have people over and we would have
a salmon boil,
you know?
So I was raised around that stuff of,
of celebrating wild game.
Having to be very social,
having to be a way to connect salmon.
Boil.
Yeah.
Boiled fish.
So you take your little,
you're just,
you're literally cubing up salmon and
Pearl onions and little baby potatoes.
Oh you.
So you're making like a stew,
a fish boil,
and then you drain it off and you have
drawn butter and you drown all that
shit.
And drawn butter.
It's good.
Sounds good.
Yeah,
it doesn't sound.
We'll do fish boils.
People do fish.
Boyles was not normal to do a salmon
boil.
It seems like it's such a flavorful fish
would lose some of that in the broth.
Yeah,
for sure.
But it's like when you.
It's like when you have the Pearl onions
and a little baby potatoes and cubed up
and you drown all that shit and bought
her.
It's just like a thing.
People like the taste is really good,
but it's not necessarily the taste of
salmon.
It isn't.
What if you went to great.
If you went to the Pacific northwest and
asked like a bunch of great chefs in the
Pacific northwest to list their five
favorite stamen preparations,
boiling them in a pot of water isn't,
isn't going to be on.
Is it going to make their list?
But he would do that,
you know,
and it'd be a thing and you'd invite
people over to do it.
So I kinda early at like early on with
all the things I enjoyed about hunting,
I'm like,
the food aspect was big for me in really
informed all of the sorts of
conversations that I've had around it
since.
And so then in doing a show about
hunting wasn't something that was going
to.
It wasn't something that I was going to
lean out.
But in all fairness,
when I was growing up,
I did a lot of fur trapping too and
trapped muskrats,
beaver,
mink,
all kinds of stuff.
And um,
was doing that to sell the sell the
furs.
And I would use some of the meat out of
you.
Some of the meat for Bait at sometimes
sell meat to dog sled racers.
When did you realize that beaver were
delicious?
Not till after.
I think I know the first one when I was
in the first one I ever ate,
I was in community college.
I still tell people about the beaver
that you cook for us and Wisconsin and
how good it is.
And they look at you sideways and Mike,
I'm telling you,
man,
it was like the most delicious pot roast
I've ever had was fantastic.
Yeah,
it was really good.
There's even stories about early on with
the one early explorers are in this
country.
They had a difficult time getting fish
sometimes.
And beaver were approved for the lenten
meal because they were aquatic.
Yes.
So on Fridays when you had to have,
like when you're supposed to have your
meat free day,
you were allowed to eat beaver meat
because they were a water animal.
It was a very popular food item.
You follow what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I get it.
The first one,
the first ones we ate,
I had started reading about,
I'd always read narratives,
stories about the mountain men.
Um,
meaning like when I say mountain,
like a very specific thing,
like a,
you know,
a rocky mountain beaver trapper who was
sandwiched between who is sandwiched in
time between the end of the Lewis and
Clark expedition and the collapse of the
beaver market in the 1840 [inaudible].
So like they're a very finite period of
time.
Was what a mountain man was explained to
people how big the market is because
this is going to blow people's minds.
Well,
America's first asked her,
John Jacob Astor,
like the beaver market made America's
first millionaires.
His fortunes came from being a beaver
trader.
The,
the richest men in the country.
Their money came from beavers.
Yeah.
And he was in on the business end of it.
He wasn't another trap and end of it.
He was in on the habits for companies.
Yeah.
The big companies,
like when we bought,
think about like this,
how big it was for us to do the
Louisiana purchase and buy that chunk of
land.
Uh,
when Lewis and Clark came out,
part of their mandate was to suss out
the potential for the trade and beaver
hides.
It'd be like buying some oil and gas.
Right?
You don't know it.
Can we justify this?
The oil and gas,
they're looking to justify it through
trade and beaver heights.
Now also,
there was also language about that.
They might find out about whether wooly
mammoth through existing out there as
well.
So there was some confusion about what
was going on.
Wow.
They really thought that woolly mammoths
were still alive.
Jefferson was interested in that stuff
because he had,
he had been to some areas,
uh,
he had some familiarity and to some
areas with these large bones and he was
puzzled the bottom.
He was wondering if this wasn't some,
if it may be in fact was not an extinct
species,
but was somehow living in the American
west still.
How hard is it to the historians,
like people,
not historian,
popular historians really loved to make
a big deal out of that.
X is so weird,
but it wasn't like,
Hey,
let's buy the,
let's do the Louisiana purchase
transaction because of the possibility
of locating Mamet's.
I think it was an idea that was floated
around.
People see it in a.
people such as me see it and perhaps
overemphasized what it meant.
But it was an idea that was out there.
The beaver trade stuff was certainly a
big factor.
Another thing I was reading about
recently that just point out to your,
to your,
uh,
that you might think is interesting is
that we as people have this idea of
Lewis and Clark going into this
unspoiled uncontacted landscape.
I was recently reading a piece by a
historian who's talking about at the
time of Lewis and Clark headed out into
the great plains.
There were native Americans living on
the great plains who had been to Europe
and met the King of France and returned
back to the great plains.
What year they,
they went out in the early 18 hundreds.
So they're out in 18.
Oh,
four.
Wow.
You gotta if you imagine the time from
the time I'm in the 15 hundreds when the
Spanish.
Right.
We're poking around and come like Corn
Otto,
right.
Coming up from Mexico into the great
plains.
Cabeza de Vaca being shipwrecked along
the Gulf coast and people pushing up
into these areas that was hundreds of
years prior.
Like the distance that separates.
Imagine the distance.
It's separated.
Lewis and Clark from the first year
peons who were doing activities in and
around the great plains is like the
distance and time that separates us from
Lewis and Clark more so.
Right?
Yeah.
It's the distance in time that separates
us from the declaration of independence.
It was like a long history of people
messing around.
Crazy.
However.
So yeah.
But think about too,
like Lewis and Clark were encountering
people who had horses.
Right?
Right.
And those horses had been his horsemen
traded up.
So that is like a side note to this idea
of eating beaver.
So I got from reading about the mountain
men.
I got interested in this because you
always do like anytime you read about
mountain and you're going to find the
part where the author talks about how
much mountain men like beaver tail and
the first people that tried and be
retailing was around when I was.
I was in community college at the time
and my brothers,
I remember stuck a b retail in the oven
for awhile and cooked it and they
reported back to me that like whatever
it is they're talking about a isn't that
like there must be some other
explanation.
Didn't we eat beaver tail?
Yeah,
yeah,
we ate it and was constantly.
We have a,
there's a,
there's a how to pictures and an
explanation of how to prepare,
how to actually prepare beaver tail
mountain man style in the media.
You're fishing game cookbook.
It wasn't bad.
It was a blend.
It's just fat.
It's so
after that we started thinking that when
they say the mountain and like be
retail,
we thought it most amended like rump
based,
like the hind quarters.
So we started when we went I would catch
beavers.
Um,
I'd be careful when Skin Adam's not get
the caster.
The beavers have two large glands on the
inside of their legs.
They're like tucked in there.
It looks like if you lay a beaver on its
back,
talked to kind of on either side of its
of its like if it's a male I talked to
you,
your side of his penis or either side of
it's Clo Eiko you'll.
You'll see a,
not waco but like vent.
You'll see these.
These glands that are the size of.
I don't know if you make like a.
If you take your index finger and your
thumb and make a circle,
there's like a gland on each side called
the castor gland.
There's oil gland in there.
They used to use it for perfume.
It still has value today.
It's used for a wide variety of things.
It smells beautiful.
If you ever walking on the stream bank
and you smell like a strange perfume
smell,
it's usually beaver caster.
Wow.
Smells great.
Tastes like shit.
Tastes like you're eating.
Like you rubbed roses or something all
over your food.
So started figuring out like to skin
them and be very careful not to get the
cast or on your knife or get the cast on
your hands and then we would just take
the meat and put it in crock pots with
potatoes and onions and stuff and just
cook them down in a crock pot.
You could pick them and it was like
roast beef.
So when I started eating that,
but I still.
Then later I realized that the read
other accounts of how people are
prepared be retail and if you take the
tail like the scaly ass tail and it
really should be from a fall,
beaver,
[inaudible] the tail would be twice as
thick in the fall.
Then in the spring or a macerated in the
spring,
take the tail into skewered on a stick
and put it next to a fire where the skin
starts to bubble and boiled away and
pretty soon you can just peel that skin
away and was hiding under.
There is the the best equivalent,
like the best equivalent or point of
comparison that I can think of would be
to just.
It's like if you had a really like
imagining you're getting a grass fed
steak,
right,
but still has that fatty gristle on it.
It's just made up of that gristle like
what allow people to trim away from
mistake and not eat.
That's what's inside that beavertail,
but people eat these individuals that
we're doing this for fat starved eating
such lean meat all the time.
I think they loved it because here's
like a chunk of fat,
you know,
and they had ready access to it because
they catching them to make a living and
if you're just eating the meat,
there's no fat on the meat.
And so they would compliment it with
just eating the beavertail fat and I'll
often tell people about it and I even
gave some to the.
There's like a,
a culinary arts institute and I gave
some chefs that stuff and everyone who
eats it points out there's not that it
tastes so fantastic,
but just like really interesting to try
and eat it.
The fat from the tail.
And it's like you've got to put yourself
in position.
You've probably been in this too where
if you're,
especially if you're out hunting and
eating
freeze dried food or not eating great
and you're just exerting yourself all
day all the time,
how you're,
what you want to eat changes a lot.
Yeah.
And you the level of appetite.
I was off the charts.
Yeah.
And so just like to eat like a big slab
of fat,
it'd be very excited.
It was appealing to people.
Yeah.
Your,
your body starts craving things that
absolutely needs.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Makes Sense.
In particularly when you think about
these people that are hiking across the
west,
traveling massive amounts of distance
and you know,
probably very physically strenuous
dragon,
all their shit with them and they get a
cross some big ass piece of fat from a
tail.
It's probably a huge treat.
Yeah.
And then our understanding of people
like we used to have this idea of like,
especially of early native Americans is
like,
they're like just eating,
you know,
nothing but mammoth meat and all the
time,
like as our understanding of people
grows,
you see like how much they are utilizing
plant resources and probably had like
pretty plant rich diets.
But with the one with the equestrian
bison hunters on the great plains,
those guys were.
They weren't cultivating at that era
like especially the era when Lewis and
Clark came in.
These people,
we're not cultivating crops.
A lot of the people who had been farming
along the Mississippi and Missouri
Valleys,
once they got horses,
they just gave up on that shit and just
started Roman landscape eaten meat and
the mountain men certainly weren't doing
that.
They were just eating like you're eating
meat 365 days out of the year and you
see that they really probably to make up
for a lot of nutrient deficiencies.
Eight shitloads.
Oregon's your guy,
the gall putting Gol on your food,
gallbladder,
squeezing,
taking the garb,
the putting,
squeezing the bile from gallbladder on
your food.
You did that once.
Yeah,
it's horrific.
Yeah.
Well they put a nine volt battery on
your tongue and you think they were
doing just because they were just
nutrient starved?
Yeah,
it seems like they,
they,
they put a high emphasis on eating just
like all these,
like just organ meats,
organ meats,
milk from milk,
from mammary glands.
Really?
Yeah.
Because you can't just eat that.
Leanne ass gave me every.
Right.
You were talking to a guy from Alaska.
What's that guy's name?
Buck.
Buck Bowden.
No,
on your show.
And he was talking about um,
you know,
essentially he was subsistence hunting
in certain stages and you know,
he ate nothing but Moose,
like he shot a moose and ate nothing but
that Moose for months and pick and
wolverine and eat off the skulls.
And so I whoa know,
you know,
so fucking modern day human who's alive
right now talking about only surviving
on the leanest of lean meat.
You know,
like I had to be skinny as fuck when
that was all over and I would mess with
that guy.
He's tough shit,
dude.
Yeah.
He,
he lived the life he lived a life that
seems like he had parts of his life that
seemed like was 100 years.
Yeah,
it could have occurred 100 years
earlier.
He,
uh,
the episode of the podcast is like,
you're a good man.
Fuck.
Is that what it's called?
You're cool dude.
Cool Dude.
Buck,
which is body mind says to him in the
shower,
you know,
he's a cool dude.
It's,
it's a treat to get a chance to talk to
a guy that you think probably never even
fucking heard of a podcast,
uh,
and certainly comes from a completely
different era.
The reason he was living had to live off
the land is an interesting story where
he was working for.
He was just getting into the guiding
world,
so guiding Moose hunters and they were
wanting to find some ways to be able to
hunt some very remote areas and they
hidden in us the idea that they would
just bring horses in because if you
don't have landing strips and stuff is
just really hard to operate out of these
areas.
So they thought,
well,
if we can get horses in there,
we'll have them in there,
will want for the season.
Then we'll ride the horses out.
But getting the horses in there,
it was so difficult.
It took far longer.
The route they wanted to use was
impassable.
By the time they got the horses in
there,
they realized that they're never going
to get these horses back Outta here and
they realize that someone needs to stay
over winter to take care of the horses
and he has volunteered to do it.
So he started spending.
They would go in and hunt in September
and then he would just start hanging out
and just stay there to agree to care for
the horses until spring.
So that's how he found himself living
out by himself.
And they would bring some food in,
but it would be never enough and he
would be eating wolverine,
beaver,
Moose,
whatever he could come up with.
But he was just,
um,
he was just open to it and didn't care
and was really comfortable with solitude
when I spend time with him,
he's very gracious.
But um,
when he spent time with them,
you see him just engage in conversation.
You see a,
uh,
a,
a sort of weariness kick in where you're
talking to someone who's very
comfortable going months without human
interaction.
Right?
So him talking to people like,
okay,
that's enough,
let me get the fuck out of house.
And you realize like when I've stayed at
his place,
his cabin and he's got,
he's got a remote cabins stolen when I
stayed out there.
You kinda like,
we'll sort of drift off and vanish for
good spells.
Sure.
Even when he's,
even when he's like entertaining,
you know,
and he sells bowls like wooden bowls for
living.
Well,
it's one of the things that he does have
one of those bowls.
I have one in my home now.
I need to get one of those bowls.
Birch.
Yeah.
It's like a,
you know,
it's like a salad bowl.
So like a growth on the side of a birch
tree that you cut off with a chainsaw
and hollow out.
Know they call them Birch Birch Bark or
burl?
Both.
Yeah.
I have a beautiful one.
And he sells and they go into terrorists
shops.
I think it's a shame that they go into
tourist shops.
Yeah,
I think he should be.
It should be all be direct consumer.
Well from him.
Why don't you hook it up?
Taking zero point zero people on the
case
gauge some of your meat.
Meat Eater.
Yeah.
He had a great many of the lost in a
fire too.
Yeah,
that was a sad story.
But besides.
Yeah.
So he's still guides and um,
does that and makes his uh,
you know,
takes some time
Berles and makes bowls out of him.
Just talking to a guy like that.
Listening to you talk to a guy like that
is so fascinating because he lives a
life that I can barely comprehend.
Just everything about it from.
And just to think that,
well,
what he does is almost impossible to
comprehend now think about Lewis and
Clark making their way across the
country and not really knowing what was
out there really not knowing like,
guessing,
having some people gave some reports.
This is what we saw here.
This is what we saw there.
They didn't even have a good account of
all the different animals.
No,
they had won or lost.
And that's the thing we were talking
about this point.
There are days we're talking about like
what people now you'll hear people say
like,
oh,
he's a real mountain man.
You know?
And oftentimes when people hear that
they imagined this old hermit,
yeah.
You know,
who's living in his cabin,
um,
him being a mountain man.
But if you think about what the mountain
men were,
they were for the time,
the most well traveled people,
right?
And the least.
Zena phobic people alive.
The equivalent today to be a mountain
man today,
the equivalent would be,
I think you'd have to go to,
um,
presuming and ascend the Amazon and
follow tributary after tributary and get
into like the borderlands around
Venezuela and then go in and despite the
language barrier,
you'd have to go in and travel amongst
and live amongst people who,
um,
tribes who had not had a lot of outside
contact but had a familiarity,
had a familiarity with outside peoples
and you'd live there foods you eat their
foods and live with them and take their
ways that they dress themselves and
adopted as your own.
The kind of guy that would do that is
not the kind of guy we're talking about
nowadays when we talk about.
He's a real mountain man,
right?
We're talking about reality show people
that people talk about now.
But these people were like insatiably
curious explorers.
They're the people now,
the people that do like go to really
crazy war zones or like decided to go
backpack up in the Hindu Kush and
Afghanistan,
you know,
just see what happens.
Um,
yeah,
very different kinds of people.
Your episodes that you did,
what?
Where,
where was that in with the most recent
series where your boat fishing with
these people?
Yeah,
down in Guyana.
Diana.
Yeah.
That's a.
that's got to be a trip.
How long were you down there for?
Oh look,
you know,
long weeks.
Couple of weeks.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
but there's a lot of travel.
There's a lot of stuff needs to happen
to get out on the river,
but when you're around these people and
they're all walking around barefoot and
they're making cassava,
which we talked about the other day,
that it could easily kill you if you do
it wrong.
The water as all this cyanide in it,
like you're,
you're about as close as you can get to
that kind of environment.
Right?
Yeah.
What you're in a situation like that you
with people who are very familiar with,
like where are you familiar with the
modern world?
Like a great awareness of it,
but like when the,
when the rubber meets the road of daily
existence,
they're still really connected to life
patterns and skillsets that were,
that their grandparents used and still
fishing like a very similar ways.
Right.
So
where you might've had,
when you were a boy lehman is someone
now is in their thirties,
when they were a boy,
they probably use a 12 pound handmade
wooden paddle and maybe now they have a
different paddler.
Maybe somehow they've come into,
you know,
a plastic paddle say and they use that
for their boat or they have a,
they still have a dug out canoe,
but they also have an aluminum boat.
So there's major differences.
But just the general sort of approach
and the fact that you're deriving all of
your protein from the river and that you
hunt and fish 250 300 days a year in the
places where your ancestors have always
done it.
You're still,
you're still gaining this really
beautiful glimpse at how people lived.
Even though they've had enormous changes
in their own lifetime and are very much
modern,
you know,
very modern,
but you can still like glimpse it more.
You don't.
I don't think you really get that as
much.
You don't get that as much here.
You know,
hunting is his ancestral.
Right,
and there's this kind of continuation
that goes on.
But when Europeans came here,
when,
when Europeans came to the new world,
they weren't coming in as hunters.
Right?
If you have to go look like Daniel
Boone's family,
Dana Boone's family came from England.
They didn't come here as hunters because
you could like the peasantry you
couldn't hunt there.
They came here and learned hunting.
So hunting and America for Euro
Americans,
hunting and America is like an
invention.
It's a thing that people kind of got to
learn and took from the Indians.
So it doesn't have a.
It doesn't have that.
Like that deep deep thread that you'd
find with indigenous communities where
there's.
This continuation has gone on for
forever on broken,
but on this continent unbroken for
whatever,
15,
16,
whatever the fashionable number is
thousands of years.
Right.
And so it's like our understanding is
different because our,
like my ancestors came here and got into
it.
It wasn't a,
it wasn't a cultural continuation for
them.
And then when you look at like for,
for food and wild game.
And an interesting thing is my,
uh,
my use and understanding of wild game is
really influenced by like contemporary
food,
right?
Like,
like restaurant food,
things that chefs do.
Like how do you take wild game and do
these like cool,
exciting,
modern,
innovative kinds of things with,
with wild game and cook it,
you go talk to her like a dude,
even though dude like Bach or
particularly people in people in South
America who have,
have haunted for more of a,
like a subsistence literally subsistence
purposes.
Their whole attitude is different about
it.
People like people in South America will
eat that.
Like the,
the Chimani or the Macuna is like
they'll eat the same thing every day for
lunch,
everyday
boiled fish with a dried pepper on it.
And then a grain made from cassava
boiled as well,
why is he a grain?
But like a dish made from cassava.
Why they boiling it?
Why,
why don't they just grill it?
They,
they,
they sometimes do.
But for lunch it's like you take
leftover.
You might,
you'd probably like smoked with.
Were they able to call barbecue fish
where you make a big rack,
you have a fire and make a big rack high
above it,
it kicks off a bunch of smoke.
You split fish,
salt,
lamb on that rack and smoke them,
dry them out,
and then you take that fish and break it
apart and poor river water over cassava.
Um,
and then put fish in there with river
water and kind of stir it up or you just
take fish and throw it in a pot and boil
it and put that on there.
But to eat that same thing every day.
Then you come and talk about,
uh,
there's no recipe,
there's no like written preparation and
then you come and talk about like wild
game cook is.
I understand that where you make a book
and it's got 100 different recipes and,
and all these ways to approach stuff.
It's just like it's very particular to
us,
like other people aren't really
perceiving it that way,
like they don't use wild game and
recipes.
They have like a,
there's like,
here's how you cook this and we don't
really deviate from cooking this way
where it's like fish on a rack over to
fire or efficient,
a pot of water and very limited diet.
Does it weird you out when you're around
people like that because you have
options,
right?
You can,
you can eat any way you like.
You can go to a restaurant,
you get a burger from fast food,
you choose to go hunting with these
people.
It's literally how they survive and
there's no option.
There's no options and they've been
doing it that way forever.
Like is it,
do you feel like a weird recreational
sort of person around them?
Like is it.
Does it feel?
That's a great question man.
I'm no,
there's definitely,
there's definitely like an,
an envious part two how to live that
deliberately.
Like I'm a little bit envious of it,
but really the thing that I feel most,
I feel I'm more than separated.
I,
I tend to feel more of the areas in
which I'd be like aligned,
you know,
where like appreciate the perspective
and I appreciate the skill set but never
feeling,
um,
yeah,
never feeling like,
like a fuller ashamed or something that
this would be something that I would
choose to engage in and this is
something that they were engaged in and
I think they're,
one of the things that helps make it
that way is how much they love to do it.
Right.
That when you go out,
like the infectious excitement of
heading out in the morning,
the fact that they still feel it.
Like there is Giddy is anybody about
going out and doing it,
like very excited to go out and do it.
It is not like going out to get your,
like to get you to check your mailbox.
My uh,
my youngest daughter has become enamored
with fishing and I love it because I get
to,
whenever we go on trips,
I take her fishy,
fucking loves it man.
And we were in Florida and we're going
to get to go bass fishing.
I set it up.
Had a guy who was going to take us out.
I woke her up 5:00
in the morning in the hotel.
I'm carrying her.
She's stiff as a board because she just
woke up.
She's like,
I'm so excited.
She was so excited.
She wasn't like,
Daddy,
I'm tired.
Can we just go back to bed now?
It was dark out five in the morning.
She's just calling.
I'm so excited that you want to have
fun.
She caught it six pound bass.
Then she's hooked.
She's got quite a few bass.
It was a great lake in in Florida,
in Florida.
Obviously a lot of great bass fishing
there,
but we caught a ton of large mouth bass
and she caught up fat boy.
It was like a six pounder.
She was freaking yet had bit her finger.
She was showing everybody look at bit my
finger.
She was so excited.
She fucking loves fishing,
but that feeling in the morning when I'm
looking at her little face and like
we're on the water,
like it's a genetic thing.
It seems like it's just in the DNA.
The fishing is.
It's not like,
hey,
we're going to go play soccer,
which she likes to,
but there's not that kind of excitement.
Now there's like,
oh,
there's gonna be so fun.
There's like,
it's triggering something that is deep
inside human beings.
I see it and I see it in.
I see it in varying degrees and in
different people.
Like some kids seem to come out of the
box with more of it.
Yeah.
You know?
My own.
I don't mean that as a euphemism.
No,
it might.
My 10,
10 year old daughter doesn't.
She's like,
yeah,
we can go fishing.
Like she's gone fishing and stuff.
It's okay.
When
I,
when,
when we had a daughter,
my wife
was adamant,
you know,
early on,
soon as she found out what it was gonna
be a daughter like that,
you will not exclude our daughter in
this world that you're in.
I was like,
oh,
of course not.
You know,
and I,
and I don't.
But uh,
having in my mind,
I don't feel like I've messed this up.
I feel like I've put the same emphasis
right on my.
I have three kids,
but my older two,
I'm the little one just a little bit too
little yet to really know what's going
on,
but the old chair,
I feel like I put the same emphasis on
it and my daughter just isn't
demonstrating the same enthusiasm that
her older brother does.
And you and you try to suss out like the
nature nurture question because I feel
like I'm doing the same inputs.
Right.
But I'm getting different results and it
leads you to wonder,
um,
you know,
it's a very small sample size,
but when I talked to other parents,
like parents who are parenting right
now,
young kids,
I just keep encountering other dads who
are having the same experience and it
really leads you to wonder,
sort of like what sort of cultural
influences are going on there,
where it's like the enthusiasm
oftentimes among young girls are not as
high as the enthusiasm among bugs.
It's hard to unpack.
I don't know.
It's hard to unpack everything.
Yeah,
that's,
that's my question is I don't know how
old your kids,
while the two on talking about are eight
and five.
Yeah,
man,
I don't know how much culture plays a
part.
I know,
I really think that it's,
and it's obviously in my small sample
group and eight year old and a 10 year
old for the youngest kids,
the uh,
the eight year old fucking loves it.
They're both girls,
the 10 year old,
she's like,
whatever,
you know,
if I tried to wake her up,
take her fish and she'd be like,
leave me alone.
I'm going back to sleep.
I'm sure there are parents out there
who,
you know,
I haven't met him yet.
Maybe they're out there where they have
like a boy and a girl and the girls
fired up and the boys not maybe
I guarantee you there's,
Jamie and I were just talking about this
yesterday because I was watching this
video of these.
There's,
I want to try to put this in a
respectful way.
Um,
I think they're,
I'm sure you're aware of this.
There's people that are in the hunting
world,
the outdoor industry that I think are in
it because it's a good avenue to get
attention.
If you're like a hot chick.
Yeah.
If you're a hot check and you know you
wear pink and you go out and shoot
things,
you take all these grip and grins with
deer and you're gonna get a lot of
likes.
Yeah.
Because it's.
Imagine the,
the male perspective on it.
Yeah.
It's like here's the woman who has
everything.
Exactly.
And she likes to hunt.
Yeah.
She's hot and she likes to hunt and
there's quite a few of them and it's.
I was telling Jamie,
it's a weird world because part of me,
I don't want to be a sexist.
I don't want to look at these girls and
I mean I don't.
I don't look at a guy who hunts and who
wants to be a part of the outdoor
industry and go,
Oh,
this guy is just doing this because he
thinks this is his avenue for fame and
success.
I think,
well,
here's a guy who really likes to hunt
and he realizes there's people like
Steve Rinella and John Dudley out there
and these famous haunters man,
I want to be a famous hunter.
How do I do it?
How do I go?
Well,
I'm going to just start taking instagram
pictures and say a lot of the same shit
that they say and sort of put myself
into the cultural norm.
I don't think like that with girls
because you're like,
you just want to.
Not all of them,
a lot of them I think are super legit.
A lot of.
But there's unquestionably this added
element in that world and it with it.
Let's be super generous and say it's
only 10 percent of them,
but that 10 percent of my smell a rat.
I'm not unaware of what you're talking
about.
Sharing.
You know?
I notice it.
Yeah.
I even had like A.
Yeah,
I remember was.
it is Kinda like A.
Yeah,
like a,
like,
like a sex pot kind of hunters scene,
you know?
Yeah.
Super made up full war paint,
fake eyelashes.
Hot as fuck.
Skin tight clothes out there.
Shooting Shit.
Taking pictures.
Yeah.
It's weird.
And then you go to their instagram page
and it's like there's pictures of that
and then there's a lot of pictures with
their butt up in the air where they're
doing some strange exercise.
Getting ready for both things and
accentuating there,
but like,
that's weird.
I don't do any of those exercises.
I really liked you.
I know I would really like to because
I'm going to continue leaning on my own
to continue leaning on my daughter
because I would really like her.
I want to keep leaning on her and so I
feel like she's in the ad age or she can
legitimately say she doesn't want to go.
Right.
Because right now if I asked her
everyday,
hey you want to go to school,
she'd be having real delinquency
problem.
So you're like,
you know,
you really like a,
you make kids do stuff.
I took her duck on a couple of weekends
ago and it was cold morning and we get
out there and before it's even legal
light,
she's felt terrible.
She's laying there crying about colder
feet are.
If my boy was doing that,
I would have a very different attitude
about it.
Then when she's crying her crank and
she's cold,
like made me feel awful with my boy.
I've been like,
suck it up for her.
I'm like,
Oh man,
she's all cold now.
Yeah,
and then it makes it so you really,
there really is a difference.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a,
there's a difference there and it's not,
you know,
the people that buy a hunting license in
this country,
90 percent of people by hunting,
90 percent are males,
right?
Right.
So one in 10 license holders is a woman,
but then there's,
there's more women than men in the
slightly more men women than men in the
country and there's a ton of ways of
explaining it.
We talked about earlier with
neanderthals or maybe an inner falls
didn't have these divided roles,
but in all the hunter in hunter gatherer
cultures is very normal to see a
division of labor here and to have like
the men were out hunting and women,
we're not.
There's a bunch of explanations for
that.
Like people were tied to being home to
care for small children and you know,
couldn't afford that risk to something.
Do they vary?
There's some women that go out with the
hunting parties,
you know,
if it is,
I mean,
you know,
the minute you say no,
someone was going to point out to some
right.
Variation,
but in your experience,
you've,
you've done several of these trips to
these remote jungles.
Oh yeah.
But that's just,
that's such a small thing.
I mean,
you get a,
rather than looking at personal
experience just from kind of exploring
literature and reading about historic
accounts and what people found in what
people do,
uh,
it is very much the norm is very much
the norm that hunting was,
you know,
patrilineal descent activity in all
these cultures.
You go to like the cult of the hunter is
like a male sort of coal,
but the factors that made it that way.
Okay.
The sort of the,
you you have to assume it comes from
some kind of practical factor.
Right?
The factors that made that way aren't
there anymore.
And I said it's a difficult thing to
unpack if it winds up being that if I
have two boys and one girl winds up
being that,
uh,
both boys become avid hunters and
fishermen and somehow my daughter does
not.
I'll probably view it as some bit of a
personal failure.
I'll never know what really was going
on.
Like I said,
it's hard to like unload it.
I wish I could have 100 children like 50
girls and 50 boys and have a bigger
samples,
but I,
you know,
I do wonder about it and what's funny
too is there's no,
like at our home,
our kids are,
our kids eat tons of wild game at our
home to the point where they don't have
any.
You could give them anything to eat.
They would eat it and it would not
register to them is unusual.
They've eaten everything right.
They've even eaten breakfast sausage
made out of Fox and beaver meat.
They've eaten Fox.
Yeah,
they've eaten everything.
Wait a minute.
Yeah.
You Eat Fox a half.
I made a batch of breakfast sausages
because I had an Arctic Fox one time and
I made breakfast sausage out of it.
What was that like?
I just caught it in with beaver meat,
a little bit.
Deer meat and a little bit of pork fat.
My kids ate it and then every wink you
try any of the Fox on its own?
Nope.
Didn't try the Fox on its own.
I've seen a ton of things,
but I didn't eat just straight old
possessed you to stuff that Fox into
that sausage.
I heard that they were good and I had an
Arctic Fox and I wanted to get a thing
made if my wife from it.
So I had a hat,
the Arctic Fox hat made for and then I
retained the meat and then we just ate
the meat and breakfast sausage and then
like if I told him,
you know,
if they were to ask like what meat it is
now I would say,
oh,
it's know this,
this and this.
It wouldn't freak them out.
It wouldn't,
it wouldn't even know.
It wouldn't even register as like a,
a thing that might seem unusual to some
people.
So the squirrel rabbit all manner stuff,
right.
The just anything.
And so I know there's no element of,
there's no influence like that with
them.
There's no influence of,
oh that's gross or you,
that's weird.
You know,
their day we were hunting the other day
we went out and we're hunting street
pigeons,
you know,
and they'll eat pigeon meat.
And where were you doing this?
In Montana.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Uh,
there's like a guy at a grain silo that
was infested with pigeons.
Folks don't know that many people
listening to this,
that pigeons were actually brought over
here as food.
And when you get like fancy squad on the
menu,
that's what a pigeon is.
No flightless pigeon pigeon hasn't flown
yet.
That's what a squad is.
So smaller and younger.
That's the idea.
Yeah.
The meats,
pinkish on the meats,
pinkish on squad if you want to get
squad.
But we used to go out and catch squads
where we had,
we had like a little,
almost like the equivalent of a little
trap line where they would,
uh,
you know,
Nasa and various places around town and
we would just know all the places to go
check to get squabbles.
And yeah,
it's one that hasn't flown yet.
So,
but you know,
people that commercially produced squad,
you can just keep them from flying.
But if you want squad from the wild,
you need to go out and you know,
you just go and collect them.
And what's the difference between pigeon
and squad in terms of the way it taste?
Pigeon meat is tougher.
Grayer,
uh,
has more livery quality and squad is
like very tender pinkish,
like it's lean.
It's not like quail,
but it's leaning way more in the
direction of quail.
Like it'd be like if a pigeon in a quail
had a baby squads more like that.
It's,
it's one of the biggest surprises I had
in.
That was one of the biggest surprises
that I've ever had in,
in game.
What if we can count that as wild game
would be what a squad tasted like
because I had been eating it for a long
time.
Eating Street pigeons because no street
pigeons,
you know,
they're around even up in the Missouri
breaks,
you got street pinch that nest up in
the,
in the cliffs and you know,
you can,
you,
there's many places you can hunt street
pigeons and they become a agricultural
past and they're not regulated.
So there's no closed season,
no bag limit,
right?
They're treated like they have no more
regulated.
Like rats.
If you could talk to wildlife managers
and ask them if they could wave a magic
wand and make street pigeons go away.
Most everybody would waive it because
they're so costly.
They're costly to cities.
They're costly to agriculture.
Um,
so I'd always eat and pigeons,
but the minute of discovering,
discovering like what a squad was like,
which is well known to people in the
fine dining,
but I had never had it.
It was shocking how good it is.
That's interesting.
I've never picked it off the menu,
but now I'm tented.
Yeah,
you should do it.
But street pigeon.
Should I avoid that?
No.
I would eat something first just to test
it and make lattes from it.
Okay.
But it's not something that you would
go,
this is one of my favorite things to
eat.
No.
Is there a way to do it where you could
really like,
is there a preparation maybe that you've
missed?
It's not bad to,
to put it in a marinade and you can
grill it.
You know what?
You want to take little brass and you
poke it whole bunch,
like poke it with a fork and tenderize a
little bit and also make some like
avenues of approach for the marinade and
grill them over.
Very hot flame.
Um,
but what was good is like to use it like
similar to like stuff with Ptarmigan or
whatever is to make patties and Tureens
Ptarmigan is something that you would
cook that way as well.
I've only seen people do Ptarmigan on
that,
uh,
with sexual called life below zero.
So a lady who lives,
she's been on the show before,
she lives like fucking hell.
What does she live like 200 miles above
the arctic circle.
Something crazy like that.
And she hunts Ptarmigan up there.
The best time I've ever eaten in this is
we,
this is in,
in our new cookbook too,
but I mentioned using Ptarmigan for it,
but it's just a,
a dish that's great for regular,
like any,
any kind of meat particularly gamers is
like you have,
you have,
you had hot pot.
Yeah.
Where you like,
where you have the,
you know,
you have like the simmering broth.
And you have all these raw like raw
sliced meats that you dip in there.
The best timing I've ever had is like
that.
Hmm.
It's,
it's other worldly,
you know,
it's just kinda like,
like Kinda like when you slice it thin
and cooked that way I just kind of
vanishes on your tongue.
It's a very,
very tender meat.
You can almost kind of mash it up.
People like a thing you hear with a lot
of gamers.
People described harm.
Again,
treat street pigeon,
lot of game birds people describe as
livery diving,
ducks being livery because it was like a
texture thing to it.
And in the strength of flavor,
in a darkness of color.
Um,
and those people make a lot of pathways.
Liver,
right?
So those birds that have that quality,
oftentimes they just,
they can find their way into patties.
So we also have recipes for that.
Like how to do pat taste from using all,
all manner of meat.
Do you have any recipes in the book for
Brown bear?
No,
but we have bare recipes.
Is there a difference?
You know,
Brown,
black bears are among people who know
blackbirds are widely accepted as being
good to eat.
If you go into,
if you go to earlier I mentioned Daniel
Boone's,
so if you go into that,
like the frontier era of American
history,
right?
Which proceeded just these little lingo
terms.
The frontier era of American history
proceeded the mountain man era of
American history with like the eastern
settlements,
right?
Um,
if you read it like about Daniel Boone's
area,
you know,
early 17,
hundreds up into,
uh,
you know,
open to the revolutionary war.
Bear me was the most popular meet on the
frontier.
Black bears.
The most popular is in preferred,
preferred over venison.
Really?
Yeah.
People hunted deer to sell deer hides
and they would eat the deer meat.
People want to barriers to that.
That's what they like to eat late.
So there's more beef like,
you know,
and you know,
when cooked right?
People love bear meat,
a brown bears.
Grizzly bears just don't enjoy the same
reputation.
Um,
different diets.
One run in with Brown when we use it,
when we use the term Brown,
like brown bear is kind of almost like
a,
like a.
it's used amongst hunters a lot,
but it is all.
It's all one species,
so whether you've got a grizzly bear in
Wyoming or a brown bear on Kodiak
taxonomically,
it's regarded as as a single species.
People Call Brown bear.
Brown bear is a grizzly.
You'll get all kinds of people.
Right,
and you to say this about various points
of this book,
like debating various aspects of this.
A brown bear is a grizzly with access to
marine resources were marine resources
make up a major component of it's diet
and then the question you bring up is
then like if you go to the north slope,
so if you go to the Arctic coast and you
saw a grizzly there,
you'd be like,
well,
he has access to marine resources.
He can eat a beached whale,
whatever,
but he's a grizzly.
So like brown bears kind of extend right
from northern BC up around and Hook
around into the bering sea,
but at some point they're just not brown
bears anymore and there he,
they tend to be big and,
and oftentimes because of the name,
like the tend to have like a darker
coloration,
they have a horrible reputation is food.
You'll always find people who will point
it out,
right.
Or nowadays because people are so aware,
like in the social media world nowadays,
you'll have people that will kill a
brown bear and here you are,
you've got four or 500 pounds of meat
and they'll talk about how they're going
to eat it.
But like dude,
you're in for a pound a day this year.
Really?
Is that really what happened for real?
Is that really what happened?
That's true.
Right?
And then there's no salvage requirement
on it.
Uh,
there was no salvage requirement on it.
Don't you have to in Alaska?
Don't you have to pack it out?
Depends,
there's some areas that have zero.
Some areas you know,
typically typically no,
but there are areas that do have salvage
requirements where I have a cabin,
there's a salvage requirement on bear
meat in the spring because in areas
where bears.
So that's a black but yours,
your cabin is that there?
It's island by island,
so somehow like the ABC islands,
like,
like you know you go to Admiralty
Islands in Admiralty Islands is all
brown bears,
so it winds up being that if the island
is good brown bear habitat,
it will only have brown bears because on
the islands where it's smaller,
they just would kill all the
blackberries.
They're there and blackbirds aren't
there.
If the island is not brown bear habitat
and can't support brown bears,
it will become a black bear island.
Prince Wales is a black bear island,
Admiral Tom Brown,
bear island and you know,
it kind of depends on how much seems to
maybe depending on how much like open
country or Alpine or you know,
if it's like densely densely forested,
it's less suitable and becomes a black
bear territory.
But black bears in the spring have a
salvage requirement because if you're
talking about coastal bears,
coastal bears are better to eat in the
spring when they're not eating tons of
rotten salmon in the fall.
There wouldn't be a salvage requirement
because when they're eating dead salmon,
their flesh can become not good.
I remember you telling me a story about
using the guy smoker and he told the
guy,
man,
you need to clean that smoker out.
Smells like fish.
He's like,
I've never cooked efficient [inaudible]
you.
You were smoking a barren it.
Yup.
And that was a.
That was an early June in early June.
Blackberry,
who's not getting salmon,
but it's just.
It stores up that that flavor stores on
their fat.
I've watched even woves eating salmon
that were so rotten that they're like
lapping it up where it just turns into a
grey Bush into the bears and people's
idea of a bear is like eating a brand
new fresh fish,
which they love to do and they seem to
prefer it.
Like when there's tons of fresh fish and
they're just getting fresh fish,
they'll just eat eggs.
Right?
But as the fish run dies down,
they just start eating rotten fish.
Um,
I can't remember how we got to talking
about quality food.
Oh,
were you asking?
So even like Mark Bowden's Buck Bowden,
who,
like I said,
he's picked the head meat off of
Wolverine skull to eat it,
but bowden and said he struggled his
entire life.
Um,
and just hasn't found a way to make
brown bears that good.
There are exceptions.
People run into good taste in one's the,
you know,
I was talking about like,
grizzlies up on the north slope have a
very good reputation.
Any black bear in the rockies,
any is good.
I mean,
I've heard stories like I had a body
that kill one over a dead cow one time
he killed and it was scavenging a rotten
cow and he had a hard time with the
meat.
But generally
bears that aren't eaten,
marine resources are pretty,
are phenomenally good.
Talk to my friend Eric Weinstein
yesterday.
He's a mathematician.
One of the smartest guys I know.
And uh,
he is been fascinated by my obsession
with hunting.
And so he started watching a bunch of
hunting things online and he said he was
very put off.
I saw people killing bears with spears
and celebrating and the way they were
celebrating about stuff.
He's like,
you found the thing,
the whole thing,
I,
you know,
and I saw his point and we had this
discussion about it where,
um,
you know,
acknowledging the need to control the
population and that this is all that
they're allocated a certain amount of
tags by wildlife biologist and this
keeps the moose population healthy and
the deer population,
oh,
all these different things.
And even that people eat them.
All those things made sense to him.
But the celebration and the all the
hooting and hollering and stuff,
he's like,
there was just not enough of a reverence
for the dead.
And it really,
really disturbed them.
Yeah,
that's,
it's a great subject and it's hard to.
It's hard to approach because.
So you find so many contradictions in
weird parts of it.
And by that I mean this,
I was having a conversation tonight with
a gentlemen over dinner and we're
talking about.
He was explained to me what is the role
of a rancher and what is the role of
farmer?
Here's the person who's bringing animals
into life.
He's propagating breeding animals with
the sole intention that they will all
die and he will make his living off of
their death,
but that person remains a sort of
cultural icon.
They enjoy like a celebration.
You know when you're trying to sell,
sell a pickup truck,
right?
If you can tie it to a rancher,
it makes that pickup trucks.
He more legitimate that celebrated
character and be like,
oh,
he's an old cowboy.
Yeah,
and we like that.
It's like,
what does it.
Not that I'm definitely not knocking
them.
Let me get where I'm going with this,
but what is that like?
That person is based off of like rearing
animals in order that they may die and
he profits from their death and remain
celebrated and then you get into the
idea of what?
In a way,
when it comes to American wildlife where
we have a population of wildlife,
many respects we have it and enjoy the
management that we do and the abundance
that we do in many ways that abundance
is supported,
bolstered,
financed by hunters,
but hunters tend to not enjoy that same
cultural support because of the death.
Well,
it's also because of media depictions.
Sure.
I think that's the big part of it.
More than even so than the if are.
If all of our depictions about hunting,
we're tied into this sort of rational
discourse and they showed all the images
from your show of animals being shot and
carefully butchered in the field and
then prepared and cooked and enjoyed.
I think people would have a way,
different perception,
but we have elmer fudd and we have the
evil hunters and the movies that are
always trying to torture the animals.
I mean it's,
it's Disney and anthropomorphization of
these animals and all these different
films and media depictions and books
that Shit and then teddy bears all these
things.
They're like stained into people's
brains of what's good and what's bad.
You know,
very few kids have stuffed cows that
their pets are,
that their toys,
they have teddy bears and maybe rudolph
the red nose reindeer.
You don't want to shoot Rudolph.
No.
It seems to.
It seems that it gets much worse and
more contentious.
The less the pop.
If the American population is looking at
something that they recognize as game,
they feel different things that they
don't recognize this game that they
don't readily recognizes game to see
that death is more abhorrent to them
even if it is being treated as game,
but like you don't like you,
you don't see social media explosions
come up around someone with a Turkey,
right?
You don't see a lot of social media
explosions come up with someone around a
white tail.
Deer.
People look at that.
They see this animal that they perceived
to be very abundant in the case of white
tails and Turkeys are correct,
very abundant.
They're familiar with them.
They're familiar with the idea of these
things being haunted and it feels
different.
Now,
if there's things where there's a
perceived scarcity,
okay,
and they don't immediately recognize it
as a food item,
it's hard for them extremely in this is
way outside of my personal area of
expertise,
but why like what goes on in Africa,
but for people to see animals in Africa
that had been hunted and they recognize
them only from like
film depictions,
cartoon depictions,
mobiles over their child's Crib,
like,
like a hippopotamus is very like,
you can't look at that and it's hard to
see that as like the harvest of game.
It becomes something very different and
it's.
We've watched it happen with bears,
you know?
Also a thing that will happen is if you
initiate the hunting of something that
wasn't hunted before,
that's very difficult for people.
So you take a state where like New
Jersey or Florida where they for a long
time historically they would have a bear
season.
They would lose the bear,
so the bear sees would go away because
of a,
of a resource scarcity.
Then later they would recover the
resource in want to reinitiate the hunt.
People have very difficult time with
that being like
if it wasn't hunted before,
how can it be hunted now?
Right,
and that trips people up really bad
where they people have are hard to get
on board with it.
If you watch what's going on with
grizzly bears around what has been
unfortunately named the greater
yellowstone ecosystem where you sort of
have this cultural custody battle around
who owns this Indiana size Hunka land
surrounding yellowstone where because of
naming,
people sort of think of it as as
yellowstone when it certainly is not,
it's a large area surrounding it,
but there we had a period where we
weren't,
you know,
we stopped grizzly hunting because the
animals are being over harvested habitat
destruction and then you go through an
enormous amount of work to recover the
species and people are extremely
resistant to the idea that you would
start hunting now that you would now
start hunting something.
You weren't hunting a few days ago.
Right.
That's like.
But it's also what you were saying
earlier that it's not recognized as a
game species because it's thought of
something you eat.
Yeah.
Like mountain lions.
Like even if mountain lions are a
nuisance,
like there was a woman that had um,
she had a depredation permit because
mountain lions had killed 10 alpacas and
a goat in her farm in Malibu and she
decided not to act on the permit because
there were so many different people that
were threatening her with so many
wildlife activists that were threatening
her and just general people online death
threats because she,
you know,
she was gonna hire someone to shoot this
mountain lion that had been.
I mean it just went on a thrill kill and
got into one of our pens,
just went ham,
you know,
and,
but people,
they think of that thing is somehow or
another better than her alpacas,
which is very weird.
No people just recently protested the
killing of tiger,
a tiger in India that had killed 13
people.
I saw that.
I put that online and people in the
comments where we were like,
fuck those people.
Okay,
you're out of your mind.
What if that was your sister when it was
your daughter?
When was your mom?
What if is your brother,
your brother?
Watch,
watch your brother.
Getting dragged away by a giant monster.
Yeah.
You know,
just because it's called a tiger.
You're cool with that.
Like,
fuck,
fuck your brother.
Is that what you're saying that this was
an interesting year.
I don't mean that.
Well,
let me finish my thought and I don't
want to sound callous when I called.
Interesting,
but Washington state had its first
mountain lion mortality,
like where a mountain lion killed a
human for the first time and I think it
was 94 years.
Oregon is when Oregon had its first in
state history and I'm with the one in
Washington killed a person.
They tracked the lying down and killed
the lion and the state fish and game
department got predictably like a bunch
of blowback for having killed and I was
talking to someone who was involved with
that and I was standing up.
I think that the blowback would have
been a lot worse had you not done it.
Yeah.
You know,
but you just don't.
You don't hear from those people,
but there is this.
Would it be blow
back?
Honestly,
if they didn't kill the lion,
the lion is just out there roaming
around.
I think people would just ignore it
because the new cycle.
So fucking quick.
Yeah,
I think they would lose.
It would get lost and trump would say
something stupid about North Korea or
whatever and people would forget.
Yeah.
Uh,
I can,
you know,
I continue to,
uh,
you know,
I continued to hunt black bears,
black bears.
It's like,
you know,
in the case of mountain lions,
you have a rapidly expanding mountain
lion populations.
There's a lot of mountain lions,
mountain lions,
or [inaudible] new territory's all the
time.
They're managed,
you know,
most states manage them very tightly
with mortality quotas,
female mortality quarters open season,
close these and permit draws,
right?
That they're managed as a game animal.
Um,
they're,
they're hunted and there's some
allowable use of the renewable resource.
And at the same time that that's going
on,
we're enjoying expanding populations of
mountain lions.
I love,
I personally welcome the return of
mountain lions to any suitable habitat
where there's enough space for them to
live without causing undue friction by
them butting up against human interests
and I encourage people who are in areas
that are being caught recolonized by
mountain lions to practice some level of
tolerance and use best,
best use practices or best case
practices around to like avoid conflict.
Right?
Same thing with bears.
I welcome the return of barriers.
I think there's a lot of areas in this
country a lot,
but there's a handful of areas in this
country that could have sustainable
populations of grizzly bears that psych
suitable habitat that is not being used
by grizzly bears and couldn't,
should be used by grizzly bears.
At the same time,
I like to see when it's appropriate.
I like to see state managed wildlife
practices and then allowable harvest of
animals.
There's a lot of people listening to
this,
the don't even understand that mountain
lions are edible and in fact you say
delicious.
I liked them.
I was eating mountain lions long before
I ever hunted mountain.
One hundred one mount line in my life
and I've eaten a bunch more net.
So I had never had the question about
it.
You know,
I'd never had the question about whether
it was good or not.
Majority of the people listening to this
right now,
I'll probably like what?
Yeah,
among among Pounds Min,
like monkey who deal lines is widely
known that it's a very good meat,
but I was introduced to it that way.
There's a place when I was living in
Missoula,
Montana as a place 20 miles east.
They're called Rock Creek Lodge and
they're famous for having this big thing
called the testicle festival in the fall
where after you castrate steers,
you know,
people will fry up the nuts.
Right.
And so the testicle festivals as big as
kind of like turning like this big head
turned into this kind of bike biker
festival,
but it was this,
this big party and it was centered
around eating deep fried cow balls and
we used to go down there all the time
and go drinking.
And
one time I was at that same place in the
spring and this guy had a pot of a
potluck,
will look like pulled pork,
you know,
Bart with barbecue sauce and he had a
bunch of bonds out and he's just giving
it away.
And I was eating it and he was telling
me how it was mountain lion meat and you
were saying you'll is he saying like
balls in the fall and posting in the
spring,
you know,
read mountain land there.
And that was the first time I had
mountain lion.
And then later I had a girlfriend who's
from Wyoming and she one day is standing
behind a guy in a.
she's standing behind a guy in a
hardware store who's buying a mountain
land tag.
And she asked him,
what do you do with all that meat?
And he didn't want it.
So she gave me her phone number.
And then when he got his line he gave us
the whole damn thing.
And so we ate that whole mountain lion
than it had when I came into other
mountain lion meat in other ways.
And always enjoyed it to the point where
I wasn't eating it because I had a moral
obligation to eat what I killed.
I was going out of my way to get it
because I'd rather eat someone else's
mountain lion than buy pork.
Is Pork,
is that similar to white meat man?
Wow.
You can take the back straps with fat on
it.
You can leave the fat on it and take
that back strap and see.
You've got a cookbook.
So they'll have,
you know,
it's probably going to have trick
analysis.
So you got to cook the one six u,
just like,
oh,
just how pork used to be a cook.
It secret the fats good.
The meat's good.
We Cook it down,
make all kinds of preparations with the
cook down.
My kids meet,
they keep a bunch of wild.
They eat a bunch of mountain lion meat,
you know,
well cooked it.
But that's one of those things that
we're not accustomed to,
but we're.
We're fine with things we are accustomed
to.
If you showed a mountain lion dead on
social media and you're like,
can't wait to eat this,
people would go fucking crazy.
Yeah.
When you saw that recent controversy
with that woman who shot a goat invasive
species on an island off of Scotland to
an animal,
they have to hunt.
They literally have to hunt them if they
don't.
If you've never seen what a goat can do
to an environment,
they just destroy everything.
They eat everything they can.
They,
they,
they caused erosion.
They,
they,
they decimate
all the local foliage.
But they weren't seeing that and I think
that they were like the people that were
upset about that.
We're really struggling to describe why
it upset them.
Even a politician to pointed out that
the person was wearing camouflage
because traditionally in Scotland you
helped with different clothes and there
was no secret that there's hunting going
on out there.
Right?
No secret at all.
It was that it's an American that she's
wearing camouflage.
She's adorned,
you know,
like,
like makeup.
And it was Kinda like a,
like this beautiful image set up.
She had a high powered rifle,
which they're already using out there
anyways,
and it was just a confusing idea in a
confusing image for people.
Had to been some old Scottish dude with
his,
with his,
you know,
deerstalker outfit,
but there's something where people are
like,
uh,
why her and why here?
Yeah.
And it also
her description of it as a fun hunt.
I mean,
people had a lot of problems with it,
but it's also,
I think because it's,
there wasn't anything else going on.
She caught a cycle,
you know,
she,
she just got,
you know,
she was headed down the river and a
tributary opened up and she went right
into controversy bank.
Yeah,
that's what I think happened in the
people that were tweeting about.
I saw Glenn Glenn Greenwald tweet about
it.
I'm like,
you're a journalist,
like you're an actual journalist to
respected journalist.
You should really do some research on
this because the way you're calling it,
I don't know.
I mean,
Glenn Greenwald is a,
I believe he's some sort of an animal
rights activist.
I don't know if he's a Vegan.
I don't know if he's a vegetarian,
but I know Ricky Gervais' isn't.
He's not a vegetarian.
He's no.
Oh really?
Yes.
That's the weird part,
right?
Yeah.
That's funny man.
That I didn't know that.
I didn't know
the on a radio show about it.
He needs me.
Yes.
We were talking about hunting and you
know,
I brought it up because we were on the
radio show together on the opiod anthony
show and I said,
I shot bears and I eat them.
I eat everything I kill and I hunt for
food and I prefer to get meat that way.
And we discussed the fact that he eats
meat.
Huh?
It's a weird one,
right?
Because it's A.
There's a virtue signaling aspect of
shitting on hunters where you're always
going to get some positive remarks about
it.
It's,
it's difficult for me.
It's not difficult for me for from
someone who doesn't.
Who doesn't eat meat,
right.
I,
I can,
I don't have any.
I don't have a problem with it.
Like I'm like,
you know,
I,
my brother said a bass like,
I don't know.
He said maybe they have a point when
it's coming,
someone who doesn't mean it winds up
demonstrate that they're trying to put
them to condemn hunters who are hunting
like a regulated resource.
Yeah.
Chicken Dem,
them.
You're sort of acting like when you
condemn you sort of acting like,
oh,
I care about these issues and I want to
be out here and I want to be like
articulating a perspective and,
and I know what's going on,
but then you're like putting yourself
out as a person who has opinions of
value,
right?
Just,
just to like let your opinion be known.
So if you're going to have that,
like where's the self examination
exactly where you are.
If you're eating meat,
like you're contributing all kinds of
animal death.
Like what is your understanding of what
is your understanding of those lives and
those deaths?
How is that not part of your reckoning?
If I do,
let's say I am happy that I got a bear
that I will eat with my family.
Let's say I am happy about it.
Um,
is it better for you that you're kind
of,
is it better to be sad about it somehow?
Is it better to be regretful or just
ignore the fact altogether or why is it
not okay that I'm happy about what I
eat?
I know the story of it really well.
Like I understand the history of
wildlife in this country.
I don't want to say better than anybody
but damn sure better than most.
I know where we've been.
I have a good sense of where we're going
in terms of American wildlife,
what the challenges are for American
Wildlife,
right?
I'm involved in this stuff on a daily
basis.
I can know all that and I can see my
place in it,
right?
I can see what my actions are and
whether my actions are helpful or
hurtful for something that I care a
great deal about and if I can know that
well and get a deer,
a bear or whatever and have it be food
and find that I'm like really happy to
be involved in that.
That somehow is off putting to people,
but it's okay to be that.
It's I'm blind to it,
I have this nagging sense of guilt about
it that I haven't reckoned with.
I don't really know about it,
you know,
and that's like,
that's like an accessible position for
some people to have.
It's really hard for me with people that
are,
that are contributing to animal death,
who,
who want to condemn those who are more
willing to or for whatever reason,
willing to excited about taking part in
the process themselves.
I got to find a way to.
I gotta find a way to,
to,
to engage with it though and I need to
get a better understanding of it because
the,
the debate isn't going away.
I can't keep brushing it off is so
ridiculous that it doesn't warrant my
time because clearly it does warrant my
time to understand that perspective.
I just haven't had anybody really give
to me in a good way to I have to say
like,
oh,
but they were raised to be eaten.
That's a foolish perspective to me is
way,
way worse.
So life condemned.
I'd rather talk to Google of Glenn
Greenwald is a Vegan.
I'd probably rather talk to someone like
Ricky Gervais' about it because I.
I assume that he's articulate about it
and he's articulate.
I don't think his position is a nuanced.
I don't.
I think there's some willful ignorance
that's a part of people that eat meat,
but condemn hunting a willful and the
fact that,
like I said,
they know that they're going to get a
certain reaction out of people when they
tweet about it on social media.
One thing,
if you're talking about someone who out
there shooting things and not eating it,
okay,
I get it.
I'm with you.
We'll see if some guy's just shooting an
elephant because he wants his tusks.
I'm on your side.
I get it,
but if someone chooses to hunt,
you know,
and an animal fill in the blank.
That might be a goat,
might be weird to you that they're
eating this thing,
but they're shooting this.
It's an invasive species.
It's actually very delicious.
It's very edible.
Prized for its meat by some communities.
You don't make any sense you're doing
this because you know that other people
are ignorant about it as well,
and either you're ignorant because
you've never bothered to look into it or
you've bothered to look into it and
you're ignoring the nuance.
Yeah.
In the case of the goat thing,
there's a little added thing.
There's an added
element that our government on the
federal level is involved.
There's a lot of state wildlife
management agencies that are involved in
trying to do a wild goat eradication
projects on islands.
Yes.
This is something that's ongoing all the
time in Hawaii.
In many other places where were were.
We're like out helicopter gunning
helicopter gunning for invasive species.
Explain to people how those goats got
there and the first race,
because this is also very weird,
um,
a variety of ways,
but a lot of things were a lot of island
species.
This is one way it happens where
invasive on islands would be introduced
by seafarers,
whalers who would want to establish food
resources along transoceanic routes so
that you could put something there and
come back and get it later,
early way like way.
He used to come out of the the,
the American Ne,
like all those famous whaling villages
in New England,
you know,
they would go down and stop in and stop
in and the Galapagos,
whatever,
gather up tortoises that they could flip
over in the whole of a boat and the
tourists to stay alive for months on its
back.
You'd have like a fresh meat resource
and as people came to understand scurvy
and realizing that fresh meat gives you
enough vitamin C to avoid scurvy that
you can get from dried meat because the
way the vitamin C behaves through the
cooking and drawing process,
but like fresh meat,
you can keep them.
Having scurvy me became even more
important than.
But people would come in and cut some
sheep,
loose cuts,
some bolts loose on an island and know
that they're going to breed and build up
a big population and that can be like a
place.
You stop in and get food and other
things get introduced in other ways.
And of course animals move,
you know,
so you have one island has close
proximity to another island they can
swim across.
Yeah.
Bump over and it destroys native
vegetation.
They trampled bird's nests and so you
have many cases where introductions of
non natives,
particularly non native grazing animals,
non native predators will wind up
causing like a lot of extinctions of
endemic species on islands and creates
all kinds of problems
and that's exactly what we're talking
about with this.
Go in that picture.
So this is an animal that must be killed
if you want healthy wildlife on that
island,
the native wildlife and the native
fauna,
the flora,
all this stuff that lives there.
All this stuff that's supposed to be
there.
You got to kill the goats.
Otherwise they'll eat everything.
But I think people look,
people look and they,
they,
they look and they're like,
I don't buy that.
That was the motivation of that person.
What I care about his motivations of
individuals.
I think you're right because when
California got rid of mountain lion
hunting,
they're still killing several hundred
mountain lions here a year.
People are comfortable,
like the total
lion kill didn't change much.
People are comfortable with estate agent
or someone being paid to go out and kill
lines.
They're not comfortable with some pain.
Who wants to go
do it?
I don't think they realize.
I don't think they realize that state
agencies are killing as many mountain
lions in California as they are.
I don't think people understand that.
I think people do understand.
If something gets put on the ballot,
would you like to reintroduce mountain
lion hunting?
People would go crazy.
Like why would you do that?
Mountain lions are beautiful.
They're exciting.
I want to see them,
but these are people in Santa Monica,
you know what I'm saying?
They're not people that are living,
you know,
an hour outside of Bakersfield and they
got 16 mountain lions in their backyard
and a year.
That's a different kind of world.
You know,
if they're in the tach p mountains out
there and you see mountain lions all the
time.
They have a lot of mountain lions.
Yeah.
And the real issue,
and there was a problem too that I view
this is coming from there's a problem or
I think a lot of people have a very hard
time empathizing with people who might
be negatively impacted by wildlife as
well in the question of the lion issue
where it's kind of like this idea like,
well you better suck it up,
right?
Yeah.
So if you're a rancher and you're
running cattle and the area where you're
losing a lot of cattle,
the walls and grizzlies people will look
and be like,
you better suck it up,
buddy.
Like I can't really picture your
problem,
but your complaints are not legitimate.
Well they can't.
If someone were to cut a.
If someone were to cut a grizzly Lewis
and golden gate state part,
right.
I don't know.
Um,
I think that people would have,
would come to have a different
perspective on that to put it mildly.
Yeah.
But it winds up being the.
You look and people are,
they don't really want to hear about
other people's problems if it doesn't,
if it doesn't jive with their
understanding of what problems are.
And that's the area where the issue
around grizzly bears and the delisting,
so you know,
they were delisted,
they were removed from the endangered
species act protection temporarily
because they had,
had met all recovery goals.
So when we look mostly recovered
population look like they mapped out
what it would look like and we've
exceeded that for many years now.
And they were delisted,
but then a Wyoming and Idaho moved to
have a very limited hunt on them.
Um,
and then they were a federal judge
blocked the listing and they went back
and listing it was the federal judges
motivation.
Well,
you want to hope that,
uh,
that they didn't have one you want,
you want to think that they were just
looking at,
you know,
the details of it.
But I think there's a suspicion that
that person went into that knowing damn
sure what they were gonna do,
you know?
Uh,
but you don't really know a lot of these
arguments around.
They'd come down to like technicalities,
right?
No one's arguing that the populations
recovering
well.
There's also the argument that the judge
is probably trying to protect his own
reputation because the amount of blow
back that a judge would receive for
allowing a hunt to go through is vastly
different than blocking a hunt.
You know,
blocking.
You Hunt,
you're not gonna get that much blow
back.
You'll get a few people that are upset,
but it hadn't been an established
resource.
Not only you're taking something away
from people,
but if he allowed it pour the wildlife.
People would go fucking bananas on this
guy.
Yeah.
They,
they tend to like,
and I don't even call them and like I
don't call them environmentalists,
people who sued to block the delisting
of recovering species,
the masquerade as ecologically conscious
environmentalist,
but they're just people who it's,
it's untenable to them.
They can't,
they're never going to accept the idea
that you're going to have human
exploitation of this resource.
Right.
Did they masquerade that they're.
They have an environmental motivation
was not.
It's like it's an animal rights
motivation.
There's a very,
there's a,
they have a sensitive ear in a certain
federal court,
you know,
in Missoula,
and so you'll see a lot of these cases
around wolves and grizzlies.
They'll get that.
They want it done through that court.
They know their going to have a friendly
take on it.
I think it was a real.
It was watching that happen and that's
been happening recently.
I think it was a real,
a real travesty because there's a couple
of things that happen like culturally an
areas where you'll.
You create a lot of tension with people
where there's people that are living
amongst these things and they're looking
for some level of some level of relief
and they want to see it go to state
management and they might want to see
the state exercise.
Some control over where certain
populations of large predators are
spreading into and when it winds up
being that they're like,
their voices are not heard,
you know,
and they feel that people from far away
are really heavily influencing decisions
that affect them on a daily basis.
It winds up creating a lot of animosity
toward the species to where they think
about what happened with the spotted
owl,
right?
The spotted owl.
No one can see.
No one perceives the spotted owl,
an owl anymore.
The spotted owl is become like a symbol
of federal overreach and you'll find
that you know wolves for awhile they
become like a symbol of a dispute and
people stopped liking the animals much
and it becomes like this contentious
creature and I think that we're going to
head that way if we keep,
if we keep stepping in on wildlife
issues with the mentality that we've
been approaching the wool from grizzly
issue in the northern Great Lakes,
the northern rockies,
soon to be in the greater yellowstone
ecosystem.
Now I think you're dealing with low
cool,
and then you're dealing with national,
right?
So the local people are going to have an
issue with it because they're going to
be impacted by it.
It's going to be directly impacting
their life.
Dogs are going to be killed while
they're gonna
take domestic cattle and all sorts of
different things.
You've got to have real issues with the
people that liked to go elk hunting.
The populations have diminished rapidly,
but the rest of the country doesn't give
a shit.
People in San Francisco,
they don't give a fuck about it.
People in Chicago aren't impacted by it,
especially if they don't have anyone in
their family that haunts or anyone that
has a background in hunting and they
don't have a background in it
themselves.
They don't care.
No.
People really don't.
And it's,
I,
I pointed out all the time,
but,
um,
that I care about the availability and
been an abundance of deer,
elk,
Moose,
Caribou,
right?
Like,
I care about the resource.
There's a lot of people who rely on the
resource,
use the resource there,
major economic drivers.
Um,
I'm definitely,
I'm anything but I'm like,
I,
I regard myself as a pro wolf person.
I regard myself as a pro grizzly person.
I cherish every interaction I have with
those animals.
Do you think to be around a number of
resource.
I don't have a problem with common
resource to people,
but people do have a problem with
calling resource and um,
and,
and yeah,
I'm like pro.
I'd like to,
in suitable habitat,
I like to see them present.
I also like to see that,
that I also like to see them managing
the way that allows for a bond and wild
game resources.
What's going on?
House passed the bill to drop legal
protections for gray wolves as past
today,
or will this interesting was two hours
ago,
so well roll down a little bit.
Republican controlled House passed a
bill on Friday to drop legal protections
or gray wolves across the lower 48
states reopening a lengthy battle over
the Predator species,
long despised by farmers and ranchers.
Wolves were shot,
trap,
poisoned out of existence,
and most of the u s in the Mid Twentieth
Century by the Mid Twentieth Century.
Since securing protection in the 19
seventies,
wolves have bounced back.
Well,
it's not really excited what happened.
Great Lakes of Michigan,
Minnesota and Wisconsin as well in the
northern rockies and Pacific northwest.
That's SORTA,
but they're not talking about the
reintroduction.
Reintroduction is the big issue.
Right.
Well,
and that's what people have great issue
with.
Well,
the other,
the reintroduction is only in one area.
The Great Lake,
the northern Great Lakes.
That was not a reintroduction.
There was a sizable population.
I will movements of wolves coming down
from Canada and coming back in the
northern Ca,
the court,
northern continental divide ecosystem.
Not a reintroduction famous.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
The famous case of the famous
reintroduction,
Yellowstone National Park,
so viewed now.
It's widely viewed now that if you
wouldn't have done that,
you would have had had you not done that
reintroduction,
you'd have had a natural flow anyway.
A natural flow from Canada.
You would have got it.
You would have,
you would have eventually you would
eventually have gotten there anyway.
Interesting.
But would they have gotten to the exact
same levels?
No,
no.
At this particular point right now as I
think that'd be like laughable to act as
though they'd be there now,
I think,
but,
but people.
There's no realization that you would
have that without the reintroduction you
would've,
through natural movement,
have eventually gotten,
you know,
do you.
I think that that's,
uh,
that the,
that supports the idea of the
reintroduction.
You think the introduction was well
thought out.
I don't want it,
you know,
I'm not going to debate the merits of
the reintroduction.
Like I said,
my perspective on it.
It should be in a place where it
supports them.
Yeah.
My perspective on it is I,
I don't,
uh,
the idea of extinction and regional
extirpation sickens me,
I do not believe in.
I do not believe that like as a people,
as a culture,
we can justify or afford to remove
species of wildlife from the landscape.
Um,
native species of wild there from the
landscape.
Like I said,
the idea of sickens me,
I like to,
you know,
I like to have all native wildlife
present on the landscape so
I don't oppose it.
What I oppose is a thing that's happened
now is getting where we have populations
that we agree like what will recovery
look like and at what point when,
how will we manage all the different
viewpoints that are coming in,
all the different interests of all these
varied stakeholders.
Net what point where we get in there and
manipulate the situation that we're
creating.
I just would move that in a different
direction where I think that when that
recovered species,
right in this case,
when we're talking about walls and
grizzlies,
I think that you should have that.
If you can do it in a sustainable way
that doesn't have longterm deleterious
impacts on the population that they
should be managed as a renewable
resource.
See,
this is where people are going to have
issues.
I don't have any.
Just even the term manage them as a
renewable resource.
You mean shoot them and kill them and
use their.
For
sure.
I think that,
I think that recovered bcs that I think
that if you put something on the
endangered species act and it goes under
federal protection,
um,
and then when it reaches recovery and
the US fish and wildlife service as it's
recovered,
it's time to hand it back to state
management.
If a state then decides that they're
going to do some limited harvest,
particularly let's say they're,
even if they're focusing on areas where
there's like very high prevalence of
human animal conflict and the state
decides to do that in some like minor
way as a way to service the needs of
certain segments of their population
that wants something to happen.
I don't think that then some like an
activist judge or or environmental
groups or animal rights groups should
come and be like,
well nevermind.
We're going to pretend that they're not
recovered now because we want to prevent
the state from doing something that we
think is unsavory.
Well,
the thought process behind the people
that support blocking the hunt is that
if you leave these
animals alone,
naturally they're going to find balance
and that the wolves will kill the elk.
Until there's not enough elk for them to
sustain their populations and the
numbers of their offspring will dwindle
and they'll get to some sort of a
sustainable level.
Yeah,
but we already.
I mean,
we live in a.
We live in a heavily manipulated kind of
land kind of manmade environment.
Now the idea that things are gonna,
we would just let things run their
course and watch what happens isn't
going to happen.
You're still going to have a lot of
grizzlies.
Every year are still going to get in
trouble.
They're still going to get killed.
You're still going to have mortality.
You know you're going to have tons of
grizzy mortality in tough areas,
but they're going to kill.
These are enacting and packs.
That's how they kill.
They kill cattle and they come up.
They brought up against humans.
It's just like,
it's inevitable.
You're gonna.
Have some that you're not going to let
it run as a.
As a person,
as a hunter.
I also don't have a problem with and
actually support as a hunter that we
would all while allowing wolves to be
present on the landscape,
that we would mitigate their impact on
big game.
I don't mind saying,
I don't mind just coming out and saying
that I like to have high populations of
big game animals that are available to
hunters and also at the same time
sharing some of that resource there.
Having wolves on the ground doing it.
I don't want to see them gone.
Not Anti Wolf,
not anti grizzly.
It's just one of those war.
It's because of wolf is so much like a
dog and because there's not a great
history of people eating.
I remember you telling me about one
mountain men were.
His favorite food was wolf.
Stefansson is the Arctic explorer.
What a crazy fucker.
That guy must've loved wolf meet.
You ever tried it?
No.
No,
no.
Levy in coyote.
You Eaten Caio.
So you've eaten that species and I've
never.
I've never killed a wolf.
Never killed a grizzly bear.
Just haven't.
Haven't eaten either of them.
I won coyote.
Yeah.
Didn't aid it.
Didn't like it.
Haven't messed with one sense.
Yeah.
You said that was similar to divert duct
to.
Right.
That was Ramey.
Ramey felt that it tastes like bad.
Diver duck diver ducks and still eat
diver ducks.
But no,
I haven't.
No,
I haven't,
uh,
haven't done that anymore.
And then,
um,
haven't included any coyote recipes in.
There was no coyote recipes in the wild
game cookbook either wolf might be the
ultimate one that people are going to
have a problem with at the very.
That might be where the rubber hits the
road.
Well,
you know,
in some places become a moot point
because Idaho,
Wyoming,
Montana,
I'm all have state management of Walt's.
Yeah.
All of the things that we're.
All these horrible things that were
going to happen when the state's resume
management of wolves didn't materialize.
Right.
But those places also have a rich
history of hunting.
Yeah.
But it was,
it was going to be the end of wolves.
Right.
It hasn't in the first few
years,
in the first few years of the wool
seasons,
he actually had.
He actually saw the populations go up so
hard to hunt them.
Right?
Well,
it winds up being the,
uh,
putting that with that little bit of
hunting pressure on them really changed
there,
really changed their movements and
change the way they perceive human
threats and they adjust to it pretty
quickly,
but it hasn't led to,
you know,
I think a lot of people look in those
cases where it was pretty effective.
It was very effective to bring in,
to bring in limited regulated hunting,
had the desire to fact on how we're
using the landscape and in ways in which
they were interacting and info and
avoiding humans.
And I have no doubt too,
I have no doubt too,
like it'll the situation will probably
in the northern Great Lakes,
they had state management,
law,
state management,
like it bounces back and forth.
You're going to,
you're going to eventually,
let me kind of depends on how the
political winds blow,
but you're eventually gonna wind up with
it there and you're not going to see
wolves vanished from the landscape.
You know,
you're just not.
If grizzly bears wind up doing it,
you're still gonna.
See,
you're gonna see gradually expanding
populations of grizzly bears to fight
despite the fact that they're using
limited harvest to achieve certain
management objectives is not going to be
the end of the world that just not.
Yeah,
I agree with you and I think the grizzly
bear thing,
you'd probably have the same sort of
situation where the grizzlies will
eventually think of people as a threat
and it'd probably be safer for
everybody.
That's one thing that people.
That's one thing that people hope,
and again,
people aren't really a lot of people
looking from the outside in.
I'm very sensitive to it.
Yeah.
To the idea of the way that which that's
you know,
that this has impacted professional
hunting guides,
hunters,
but these are my people.
These are people that I care about and I
care about their needs.
Right.
And it's an issue.
So time will tell where that,
where that winds up.
Well,
we see an MBC where they've just taken
it away and they take it.
They've taken it away in a very
irrational way because they have a large
population of grizzlies and pc.
It's very large and for people that live
up there that,
that hunt them,
this is kind of scaring the shit out of
them that all of a sudden you've taken
this away.
First of all,
it was a source of income for a lot of
these people that would guide them,
but it was also a smart thing to control
the population and keep them away from
humans.
Well that I watched that closely though.
I don't feel it being another country,
you know,
you don't have that sense of um,
being that other countries don't have
that sense of the,
of that you could influence,
you know,
so it's Kinda like watching something
happen in a distant way and you don't
feel it as closely and I don't know all
the factors that play as well as I do
here.
Well,
I have some friends that live up there.
My friend Mike [inaudible],
who's a guide up there and he told me
horror stories about grizzlies had shoot
one trying to get into his cabin from
six feet away and you know,
their,
their big fuckers,
they are,
I love them to death.
They're great.
I mean,
it's cool that they're real.
it really is.
It's a wild thing that there we have
this huge monster that lives in the
woods.
I haven't been charged by him.
I wouldn't change a thing,
man.
You were charged by.
I'm,
I like having.
I like every encounter in every mixup
and it's really,
it's like deeply complicated stuff in
when talking about these things,
it's also they become like everything
they become a proxy were,
were,
were we're engaged in a debate about
what is,
you know,
we're engaged in debate about like
conflicting views on wildlife and these
animals step in to this debate and the
debate centers around them and it winds
up being bigger than a debate about
grizzlies.
Bigger than it is a debate about bison
or buffalo,
right?
Bigger than a debate about wolves.
It's just that these animals step into
this ongoing dialogue about what is our
relationship with the natural world?
What does that relationship with
renewable resources,
what does that relationship with rural
versus urban perspectives on how people
should be around wildlife can be
impacted by wildlife and so it's this
through line of us trying to sort out
how to be like good,
responsible stewards of the landscape
and that debate always centers around
these things.
Like you could have a huge argument
you'd be like in a lot of tension with
your spouse.
Right?
And it springs up in a debate about how
best to load the dishwasher or who was
supposed to pick up the kid from school
and there's always like,
it always finds a place to live.
Um,
and right now we're like this argument
about American wildlife and what is our
relationship to it has found its place
live right now around large predators.
And in Scotland it's found its way to
live around a feral goat on an island.
Well,
that one case,
all the traveling that you do and all
the hunting trips you go on this,
has it gotten to a point ever that it
seems like a job?
Yeah.
As now that I have kids,
I,
it's changed a little bit,
I view it a little bit differently,
um,
but no,
I still,
I still really love it and I'm able to
know that I'm able to know that I'm
missing my family while I'm out.
I'm,
I'm able to know that and feel that pain
and still know that I love what I do and
I love talking about the things that I
talk about and,
and you know,
and I view it like as a,
as I'm sure you do,
like it's like this tremendous privilege
that you're able to,
uh,
Kinda grow up to have to have this like
intense interest in the subject and this
intense stress and lifestyle and then
have the ability to like introduce
people to all these different ideas.
Uh,
so yeah,
I can have those two things
simultaneous.
I'm the kind of long to be home more but
enjoying being out.
I think if it would,
if the longing to be home more would
override that someday it might change
it.
But right now I'm,
you know,
I've just have seen so many things that
I'm happy to have seen and to think
about a future of not accumulating those
experiences at the rapid rate that I've
accumulated.
And um,
it kind of bums me out a little bit.
Yeah.
You've lived 100 lives,
you know that the trip that you were
talking about when you were in South
America and the jungle and you came
across those pictographs.
What do you say?
How do you call those things?
Petroglyphs.
Petroglyphs,
petroglyphs on the rocks that no one had
any idea who made no one know why they
were just there.
Now it's not like a spot on a map that
tourists go to visit.
Oh,
here's the petroglyphs.
No,
they're just there.
They're just there.
And the hunters like,
yeah,
there they are.
The ancient ones made these,
hey,
let's get the fish.
You know,
they,
they really don't give a shit,
but it's like,
you're,
you're seeing who knows how old that is.
Thousand years old years old.
Yeah.
To run into stuff like that.
Beautiful experiences,
man.
And then the,
you know,
to eat the way I eat and live the way I,
it's,
yeah,
I feel fortunate in all the time.
Well,
I think you're very important because
there's a,
there's a real lack of well-read,
articulate people that support your
position that are in the media.
I mean,
you got a lot of these shows that are on
these,
the hunting networks that they appeal to
a very narrow bandwidth in this narrow
bandwidth is,
you know,
just uh,
it's,
it,
it's like your stereotypical idea of
what hunting is to a lot of people.
So they'll flip through the channels
that watched that for a few minutes.
You see someone hooting and hollering
after they shoot something and they get
this bad taste in their mouth about it.
Whereas I tell people all the time,
if you really want to get an
understanding about what hunting is
about,
I always recommend your show because
your,
your narration and your reverence for
what you're doing and the animals and
just,
uh,
your,
your appreciation for how cool the
experience is and how wild it is,
you know,
for lack of a better term to just,
to be out there in nature and to be in
the pursuit of these things.
And then the,
take these things,
these wild creatures and feed your
family and have it become a part of your
life and to sustain yourself with it.
Primarily,
it's a,
it's you,
you're giving a perspective that I don't
think is available that I think is,
uh,
is important because it's just,
there's so many people out that are out
there that are hunters,
that are smart,
well read people that feel frustrated
like,
God.
I wish everybody could see it the way I
see it.
Yeah.
I think it's poor.
And to point out that my love of hunting
and fishing and of living like a hands
on relationship with the natural world,
living in close proximity to wildlife,
like my interest in that and desire to
do that,
uh,
predated by a long ways.
My ability to talk about why I think
that those things are important.
It was there.
It wasn't like I didn't grow up around
that.
And then later started understanding
this stuff and thinking about it and
then decided like,
well,
the path for me then considering what I
know now,
the path we then would do to figure out
hunting.
It was like hunting was there.
I loved it,
I love it today.
And I just had the luxury through what I
do for a living to spend a lot of time
thinking about,
well,
why is that the case if this feels like
harmonious to you and you can kind of
live in this and understand and see how
you fit into some greater,
you know,
ecological picture,
right?
Um,
if it does feel that way and that seems
to be true,
how is it that like why is that right?
And it was pushing at those edges that I
eventually developed a way in which I
talk about it now.
I meet all kinds of people who live that
same lifestyle that I lived growing up
and when I talked to him,
a thing that they appreciate is just
that,
that someone is articulating to them
something that they felt to be true and
knew to be true but just hadn't had the
time or you know,
didn't have the time or ability to
really go out and express it.
So I just,
I would never want to act like,
like I've been,
like,
I certainly have not invented some way
of thinking about it,
like elbow leopold in Theodore
Roosevelt,
Gifford Pincho,
uh,
throughout history like Jim Harrison and
Tom mcguane for contemporary writers.
There's been,
a lot of people have been saying and
talking about an experience in the
outdoors in a way like,
I haven't invented some new thing.
I'm just like,
I'm trying to.
I'm working toward like articulate and
expressing something that has been in
existence for a long time.
If people see negative stereotypes when
you're on youtube or see negative
stereotypes on certain television shows,
a lot of that stuff is self feeding,
you know,
I think a lot of that stuff gets created
because it does have a shock value to it
and I would think that that minus the
camera,
a lot of minus the camera,
a lot of activities that people might
feel are abhorrent might not even be
taking place where there is a hamming it
up for the camera that goes on.
Interesting.
Do you think that there's like a sort of
a stereotypical pattern they feel like
they have to fall into so they fall into
it when the camera's on,
like a Dj Strip club voice?
Yeah.
I think the only thing that,
there's some of them,
you know what I mean?
I think there's some of that.
I think there's [inaudible] and there's
also lay people a thing that happens
with people who feel under attack.
Um,
and,
and in many ways,
you know,
hunters are under attack and a lot of
ways and a lot of places.
And I think that there's a way when
you're,
you feel like you're being attacked,
you feel like you're being pigeonholed,
stereotyped or response is to cram it
right back down someone else's throat.
Right,
right.
You're like,
oh,
I'll show you.
And there's definitely that stuff.
Or like you fall into this,
us against them,
you know,
fuck down.
Like I'm gonna,
you know,
I'll show them how we really are.
Right.
And you,
you get into this kind of dialogue
thing,
it's a lot more pain.
It's more painful.
I think I'm maybe not more painful is
definitely more hard to be like,
okay,
let's,
let's talk about this for real.
This is really something we need to
discuss.
Let's dig in and discuss it.
And I think that a lot of people feel
like I'm.
That hunting feels like something that's
natural with them.
They like to do it and they don't feel
the need to take the time to explain it.
And when questioning when pressed to
explain it,
they maybe kind of lash out,
you know?
Yeah.
It may be lack the ability to look at it
from an outside perspective because it's
been a part of their life their whole
life and they don't want to justify it.
Um,
yeah.
It's salt.
There's also the weird thing that as
much as you can appreciate hunting and
think of it as an ethical way to
acquire,
meet everybody,
can't do it.
We've got too many people.
It's untenable and that,
that's,
that's uh,
I mean there's no responsibility for you
to acknowledge that,
but it's,
it's something that gets brought up when
people talk about the,
the how ethical acquisition of meat is
really like either hunting or you'd have
to raise something yourself and be
absolutely aware or get something from a
farmer who's,
you know,
completely ethical from,
from birth to death and you have to be
comfortable with that.
But the most ethical,
in my opinion is a hunting.
But then people always say,
yeah,
but everybody can hunt.
Okay.
But I can.
So if I can,
what do I do about the fact that
everybody can.
Well,
everyone could come in.
It's a moot point because it's just,
it doesn't matter.
I guess they're not going to,
but no,
certainly everyone could enter into the
hunting game,
you know,
you could come in and hunt.
It would just mean that you had a much
larger pool of people after a limited
resource and that limited resource would
be allocated in a different way.
Yeah,
you could have total participation and
it would just be that every person's
slice of the pie will be much smaller,
but it's not,
you know,
when we look at when a statement like
looks at like,
what's,
uh,
what,
what's,
what's a Turkey harvest that our state
could support these,
break the state up into a bunch of
different units.
They look at population trends and they
determine like,
how many Turk you can we afford to
harvest without impacting the Turkey
population?
Right?
If everyone in the state wanted to
chance use the lined up with the same
number,
you'd wind up with the same number of
Turkey's being killed.
It would just be that you would have
less opportunity.
You have to wait longer to get your
turn.
So it's not that everybody can't.
Um,
I,
I don't think that,
but it's not even really point because
everybody will not,
when I do the stuff that I do,
like in,
in writing a wild game cookbook,
I'm doing two things and running wild
game took,
but I'm doing the main thing that I feel
is the most important part of my job are
the most important part of what I am is
I'm like having a conversation with
people who live this lifestyle,
right?
Like those are people that I relate to.
I want to represent the world in a way
that it enhances their lives,
provide education,
right.
And share my experiences with an
audience of people that I recommend is a
tribe that I'm part of,
which would be like American hunters and
anglers.
And I'm presenting them like doing a
cookbook.
I'm presenting them like best practices,
how to sort of like live the best
version of a wild game lifestyle that
they can.
Here's the way to think about and
approach wild game.
But uh,
but also the secondary part,
what I'm doing is presenting a world to
people who might be unfamiliar with it.
And yes,
do I have the hope that people will like
say,
read this book and then be like,
man,
I want to participate in this lifestyle
that could mean as much as I'm walking
down to the local river in their city
and flipping over rocks and picking up
crayfish,
but it is introducing them,
bringing them into the natural world and
bringing them into engagement with
nature and I do view and hope that that
will happen.
Will it happen in some grand scale where
we'll have hundreds of millions of
hundreds in this country?
Now?
That's not going to happen,
but I do think that it is important that
we do have more people involved.
We in large measure,
we fund much of our wildlife work and
management from law enforcement disease
research on and on.
We fund that stuff through hunting and
fishing licenses and through excise
taxes on sporting goods equipment.
If the more people that are engaged with
this activity,
I think the better it winds up being for
American wildlife.
I agree,
but the idea is that everyone can't do
it.
So the idea that you're saying that this
is how you ethically acquire meat,
this is not a,
it's not a solution for everyone,
but I don't,
I don't,
I don't say that this is the only way
saying you.
I'm saying this is one of the arguments
that people make.
If you say that,
you know,
hey,
I hunt for my meat.
This is how I ethically acquire me.
Well,
everybody can't do that because there's
not enough animals.
Good.
That's true.
Everybody can't do that if,
if even more people got involved.
I mean it's not,
it's,
it's not a solution for the entire
population.
You can say,
well that's good.
The entire population is not going to do
it anyway,
but it's a that gets into it.
It's a stranger.
There's just the giant number of human
beings that need to be fed.
Yeah.
There's almost no other solution than
the solution that we're doing right now.
Unless they come up with some sort of a
lab created meat or whatever the fuck
they're gonna come up with next,
which they are.
Do your lips are curling as the
involuntary?
I said,
yeah,
I'm pretty happy with,
uh,
I'm pretty happy with my diet right now.
Yeah.
And um,
uh,
but,
yeah,
I watched that kind of stuff and I'm
curious about it,
but I don't,
I don't take it as a personal insult by
any stretch now if everybody switched
the lab created meat,
but I still had the in.
I still had the ability to continue
eating how I live,
how I live,
like I don't view that as being a future
problem.
Rocky Mountain Elk Federation is
reintroduced foundation.
Yep.
What I say,
Federation Foundation,
um,
they've,
they've introduced elk too,
a lot of different places and made
sustainable populations that are now
hunted.
And this is me,
this is a beautiful thing and I'd hope
that they continue to spread and
continue to do that.
Do you think it's possible that other
game animals could be reintroduced to
places where they would develop such a
large population that we could sustain
maybe even double the amount of hunters
that we have now?
Is that possible?
Well,
put it this way,
yes.
Okay.
For Stars,
yes.
You know that you just pull up an
article about wolves united selling like
every article from mainstream news
sources to get that involves wolves.
You'll,
you'll kind of detect the bias of the
individual writing it and they're saying
how walls have only been recovered
across 10 percent of their historic
range elk.
That's about the same for elk.
Yeah,
right.
Elk are missing from 80 plus percent of
their historic range in the lower 48.
Right.
But we have,
you know,
at various times may have a quarter
million of them live in Colorado or you
know,
some states got $100,000,
whatever you get now,
perhaps 20,000
living in Kentucky,
those were all gone.
New Mexico at a point had zero,
right?
Michigan,
zero,
Kentucky,
Pennsylvania,
zero elk were gone from the unregulated
slaughter of the market hunting era when
people could shoot,
meet and sell it into urban meat
markets.
Right?
They eliminate American wild game before
we figured out how to do what the word I
keep using all the time now,
which is regulated,
harvest,
regulate,
uh,
management.
Um,
so all that stuff was gone later.
Their estates where there was no,
uh,
states where there was no deer hunting
at the time of European contact.
We had turkeys 39 states.
It got whittled down to target in 19
states.
You don't have Turkey hunting seasons in
49 states.
We've done a tremendous job of
recovering wildlife,
particularly a tremendous job of to
demonstrate like what happens to an
animal that hunters value and love and
are able to use as a renewable resource
is those species tend to really enjoy a
lot of protections and they thrive
because people are vested in their best
interests.
So yeah,
we've created Turkey hunting seasons in
30 states.
So yes,
you can recover what you can do things,
a wildlife and like create resources.
The fact that we now we used to argue
about what's gonna happen with dear,
we're going to let dr deer to extinction
in certain states or extra patients.
Certain states now are big argument is
what do we do with having so many deer
here?
It winds up being that you come up
against social tolerances.
It's hard to like when we fill in the
map on elk,
when Rocky Mountain Elk Foundation looks
and filling in the map on elk,
you got to sell people on the idea that
you're going to recover elk and there's
a lot of resistance to recovering
wildlife because a lot of so it's
inconvenient to have around.
They do a great job of brokering deals
with states and finding places where you
know a state maybe has a patch of
habitat they think could support the
animals and providing the expertise and
financial support and all that stuff
like bringing in those things,
but generally you wind up where because
of settlement and cities and suburban
areas,
we wound up with fewer and fewer places
where we can go and do it.
So to really fill in the map on,
on recovering elk across all that range
where they're supposed to be.
I don't know that we'll get there,
but we've gotten there in a lot of other
stuff and it was like the wild sheep
foundation,
right?
They're trying to do the same thing with
bighorn sheep.
There is not even social attitudes.
There winds up being disease like they
spent from domestic sheep.
Yeah.
Their main,
like the main problem preventing us from
recovering bighorn sheep is disease
types of pneumonia.
The come from domestic sheep.
Wow.
And people you know,
to go in and say to someone who's
running sheep on a mountain domestic
sheep on a mountain and say,
Hey,
no insult you and no insult to the,
you know,
your forebears who've been sheep
ranchers here for 120 years or whatever.
But we would like to try to recover
American wildlife and bring big horns
back to this mountain range and that's
going to require you moving these sheep
out of the way.
It's an insulting idea that people.
So there's a blocker there and every
animal has it's own type of problem.
Turkeys.
It worked because people don't,
don't get pissed about tr,
you know,
like having them around and then look at
what's going on with just allowing,
you know,
allowing bison the walkout of
yellowstone national park.
It's been an issue for a quarter century
now.
People are like,
I'm not comfortable with you letting
these big ass things walk out of the
park and roam around because of disease
grazing.
Right.
There's like people don't want to be
inconvenienced by wildlife.
These are places where I would be like
in that area.
I'd really like to see like when a.
When a.
When a bison leave the park,
he stops being a wild animal and becomes
livestock.
What's going on with that American
Savannah thing?
What does that,
that,
that program.
The Apr?
Yeah.
What do they call them?
That again?
The American prairie reserve.
Yeah.
What is going on with that?
Explained what the fuck that is because
this is crazy.
I mean,
I know it's a long story too long.
Yeah.
We're gonna have.
We're.
We're working with having the.
It's too long.
We're working with having the founder on
our show.
Yeah.
To have a conversation.
Prayer Reserve.
They're essentially trying to do is
reintroduce a bunch of animals into a
gigantic chunk of land and they continue
to buy up more of this land and why
aren't they running block management on
this as well?
Yes.
There's a lot.
There's a lot,
yeah,
there's a lot of suspicions and
controversy and it's like a,
it's a,
it's an idea that a lot of people are
uneasy with,
but the problem,
not the problem.
The thing is it's like people who are,
you know,
they,
they have uh,
they have funding and have a thing where
there,
when land comes for sale,
they buy it and the goal of buying up
the land is to turn it back into,
you know,
turn it back into wildlife habitat for
native wildlife and at wine.
It's contrary.
It's the controversy around.
It stems from the fact that some people
don't like to see areas that were
supported like traditional economies in
rural areas like cattle ranching and,
and to see these,
see these areas returning to a wild
landscape is threatening to people from
the hunter perspective is they're
allowing.
There's lot of places that people used
to be able to hunt and the American
prairie reserve is allowing hunting to
go on and people are coming in and
saying,
well,
they need to make sure that they need to
assure us that hunting will be allowed
here in perpetuity.
And because we're suspicious about
what's going on,
so there's a lot of,
like,
you hear about it in so many ways,
but the core mission is something that
most people,
um,
when you look at it,
the core mission,
something that most people are going to
look at it and be pretty comfortable
with,
be like,
okay,
you're a guy or an organization,
you have money.
And when a ranch comes up for sale,
you buy it on the open market.
Seller names is price.
You pay,
the price is now your land if you choose
to not run cattle.
But wanna have bison roam around on it.
Why should I care?
Right.
But people do care because they look at
it as being like a value judgment.
Uh,
they look at it as being like a value
judgment about rural economies and about
agriculture.
Oh Huh.
I didn't think
about that.
And there's a thousand more aspects of
this were like,
it's a rich subject.
Dude.
I'd love to get into it more about it.
Next time I come on.
Okay.
Next time you can take like an hour to
explain the situation.
What is their long term plan like?
How long is this going on for?
It's been going on for quite a while,
right?
Oh,
the longterm play is that overtime you
would assemble a p,
a chunk of the great plains that is far
bigger than yellowstone national park
that supports a thriving population of
Bison Wolves,
grizzly bears,
um,
you know,
in a,
in a park like setting,
but it doesn't come without a,
you know,
it doesn't come without its own bits of
controversy
and
yeah,
again,
it's like it's the thing that everyone
has opinions about there.
There was a version they don't like to
talk about that.
There was a version of this called the
Buffalo Commons that happened long ago
where a,
um,
there was a social scientist named,
I think it was frank popper by the last
name of popper and he was looking at
demographic patterns on the Great Plains
and he was observing the ways in which
the,
the gray areas on the great plains,
where the population was shrinking.
Okay.
So there's a lot of counties and on the
Great Plains where through various like
longterm agricultural trends and other
issues where the human population is
rapidly shrinking,
rapidly declining.
And this sociologist brought up this
idea that if these trends continue,
you're going to have this rare case in
which a landscape sort of accidentally
rewilding.
Okay.
[inaudible] where everyone left,
which is not a story we're familiar with
when we look at what happened.
So wildlands,
you know,
across the world,
right?
The general stories like people move in
and wildlife moves out.
So this idea that became the Buffalo
Commons.
Okay.
And that was,
it just so happens that,
that idea that this,
the idea kind of centered around this
area on Jordan,
Montana,
right?
Because you have large tracks of
federally managed public land up there,
you had a lot of ag like ranch land that
wasn't that expensive and people could
buy it.
And that was like the seed of the idea.
I think that now that was such an
unpopular notion because it had to do
with like economic decay,
right?
And shrinking towns and reduced
resources for public education and all
that kinds of stuff that comes from
having an economy that is not thriving,
but over time that like Buffalo Commons
idea kind of segwayed into this American
prairie reserve idea and it happened to
be sort of centered around the same
chunk of land.
Bill Kittridge,
a Western writer who deals with a lot of
landscape and environmental issues,
was talking about a in the wake of the
Buffalo Commons idea and poppers work
was talking about going to Jordan,
Montana and talking about the Buffalo
Commons is a great way to get your ass
kicked because it's this idea like if,
if culturally,
like the agricultural producers and
ranchers were celebrated and they made a
civilization out of the wilderness and
they brought an animals and created
economies and creative communities.
And for someone to now say,
you know,
thanks,
but no thanks bro.
We'd rather go back and eliminate your
presence on this landscape and we don't
in fact value what you did.
And we're going to try as hard as we can
to undo what you did because we now view
it as the you did the year people did
the wrong thing.
We're going to correct that wrong.
And some like it.
Some people it's like this insulting
idea to a lot of other people,
they celebrate it because they're like,
hey,
if it's for sale and I buy it,
it's mine.
I could see it from both perspectives.
German,
it's,
it's.
It's very much like the hunting thing.
If you're a part of it,
you have a deep history in it.
You understand that your perspective of
ranching is from a rancher.
Whereas people in the outside
conveniently can be ignorant about it
and go,
oh,
fuck those ranchers.
I want to see the buffalo.
Yeah.
In my perspective,
my perspective on wildlife has been,
it's the thing that you.
It's the thing that you care about,
your work to conserve.
You want to have it on the landscape and
you also eat a lot of it out of it.
That's a foreign idea.
Yeah,
it is.
I'm glad that you can't sell wild game.
I'm glad that mark and hunting is not a
thing.
However,
I would really love it if there was a
restaurant where you could go where you
could buy like really well prepared wild
game dishes,
like a really well prepared bear.
Really well prepared mountain lion,
well prepared,
you know,
fill in the blank with the animal.
I just think that would be a fascinating
place to eat,
you know,
and maybe maybe if they could do
something like that,
it wouldn't be that you could actually
sell the meat.
I mean there have to be some weird work
around it.
Have to be like someone have to come to
one of my dinner parties.
I would have.
No,
that's fine.
But I mean,
but I would like it if there was a place
where the general public could
participate in it,
I think they'd get a better
understanding and like I put up these
posts all the time of elk that I cook
and people like,
God damn,
I want to eat some of that.
I eat that.
How do you eat that?
You got to go get one of them.
You know?
I mean,
it's the only way you can eat that.
Yeah.
Well you can buy.
Come to my house.
Yeah,
you can go and buy the farm raised
version,
but then that's one.
Yeah.
Good luck getting a farm raised
blueberry,
black bear.
Yeah.
Well No,
not that case,
but like,
you know,
you could buy,
but then it's,
that's a whole other conversation around
the captive service industry.
But yeah,
you can buy,
you can buy elk that are raised on a
ranch environment.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean as long as you're getting it from
New Zealand,
you're not dealing with cwd in lot of
the other issues that they're dealing
with in America.
Right?
Well,
yeah,
but I mean they're,
you know,
those places are tested in herds that
have cwd Nmr destroyed.
Right.
Um,
yeah,
but the.
Well the whole New Zealand thing,
there was an interesting thing that you
brought up on your podcast recently.
Um,
how New Zealand,
they've been talks about actual
eradication and one of the arguments
that hunters always use is,
hey,
we're controlling the population.
This is a good service that we're
providing.
And then the government comes along and
says,
well how about we take care of that?
And everybody's like,
Hey,
well not so fast.
Yeah,
it's a that takes place in Australia and
New Zealand where they have these like
thriving very robust populations of non
native wildlife and the government has
all,
does,
has always and does now do a lot of
calling of these animals.
They don't have predators,
right?
They have like extremely,
like they're very fecund,
extremely high reproductive rates and
they,
the government is actively engaged,
you know,
around the clock gunning wildlife from
helicopters shooting,
just letting it run and shoot and leave
it to rot because you have to because
they're trying.
You have to.
But they do that because they're trying
to protect certain ecosystems and keep
like a lot of native plant species from
going extinct and fragile environments
and all kinds of reasons.
Like said there's no death,
right?
There's no,
there's no credit.
There's no Predator control on.
Which is huge.
And in a lot of places,
just completely inadequate amount of
hunting and a thing that hunters have
eyes been able to say in Australia.
New Zealand as they've been in a little
too with an a in a culture where,
particularly in Australia,
like a culture that seems to be not as
friendly toward hunters as they are in
America.
You're able to say,
well,
you know,
we're participating in wildlife control.
And then later when people come up and
they talk about,
well,
you know what,
we're going to get serious about this
and we're going to really actively with
a goal of like totally eliminating these
species.
People are justifiably made uneasy about
it because it's a,
it's a thing that they've come to
appreciate and rely on in a resource
that they want to use.
And now they're like,
whoa,
wait a minute.
Oh,
kill them all.
I do like them being here and it winds
up putting you in this weird.
Like it winds up putting you in a,
in a weird rhetorical position.
But I understand where they're coming
from because if,
um,
if you could live there and you could
agree that we're going to have some
small number of them on the landscape
and then we're going to use those and
we're going to hunt those.
And eat those.
Um,
I also,
if someone said,
hey,
they're gone now,
I would be bummed.
Yeah.
I Hunt Turkeys that I was saying
earlier.
We had turkeys in 39 states at the time
of European contact.
We have turkeys and for United States
now I hunt Turkeys and a lot of those 10
states that didn't historically have
turkeys and that do now.
And I generally have a perspective of
trying to preserve native wildlife and
trying to control non natives because I
don't want to wind up with sort of a
like monolithic wildlife pattern or the
same super resilient adaptive species
such as Canada geese and rats and white
tail deer take over the entire country
and pigs.
So you're like,
yes,
I want like the variety.
So I'm generally like,
antagonistic toward non natives.
But if someone came and said I'm okay,
you know what,
we're going to actually go in and kill
off all the turkeys.
And those 10 states that historically
didn't have turkeys,
I would say like how,
you know really because I've kind of
grown to really like those turkeys and
they're not really causing a problem.
Right.
And I think that some people,
you know,
if the New Zealand hunter and Australian
Hunter,
I don't think anyone's arguing,
there should be no control,
but I think that they're like,
let's find a balance.
I think we can find a balance with,
there's some availability animals on the
landscape since they've been here since
the beginning of our,
you know,
experience on this continent.
Uh,
if there's some availability of animals,
that's fine.
Like a reasonable compromise here.
Well that was one of the discussions as
well about Hawaii,
right?
Like,
and some of the Hawaiian islands
eradicating the pigs.
And then the Hawaiians were saying,
well,
they've been here as long as us.
Yeah,
we've both been here that our ancestors
have been here 1100 years.
They brought the pig with them.
How am I a native Hawaiian?
And the pig has the go.
There's like,
maybe you people ought to go.
I always like again,
man,
I always instinctively when I hear stuff
I instinctively lean in on.
I instinctively lean in from the
perspective of,
you know,
instinctively lean in from the
perspective of the hunter and Angler,
you know,
and like,
and,
and I love all these little debates and
I think that they're all really helpful
and interesting.
But um,
no,
I feel like I can recognize their pain
and that can also look far away and,
and laugh at the absurdity of it.
Like I even had a guy write me from
Australia and say this is a real bummer
because it exposes us to the thing where
we got to say like,
yeah,
you know what,
I wasn't really just doing it because
I'm trying to help the ecosystem by
eliminating non natives.
Um,
I actually like having someone around
and now I just got to come out and say
that.
And that's a bummer.
I wish.
I really do wish there was some sort of
a restaurant.
I think there would be a great place for
people to get a perspective.
There's no way to do that though,
Huh?
No,
but I know there's not.
Well,
I mean,
not for all the things that you're
talking about now and I don't,
and I don't look too,
um,
there is talk of a lot of people are
looking to um,
are,
are pushing for this idea that in areas
that have too many white tail deer,
um,
there's people who are really pushing to
reopen up the sale of,
of wild harvested dear as a solution to
dear overpopulation.
But um,
but for me from the perspective,
from my perspective and from the damage
that was caused by unregulated wildlife
slaughter,
I'm just,
I'm very,
very uneasy with it and I do not picture
myself ever coming around and supported
the idea that we would start marketing
a,
that we would start marketing wild
cervids
no,
I agree.
And I think that just the sheer
possibility of fuckery and people
shooting them and coaching them and
selling them and it's just,
and,
and just,
it's a,
it would increase the commodification of
wildlife.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and that's something that,
and that's something that I'm also just
uncomfortable with in general,
the commodification of wildlife and I
think about resource availability for
hunters.
And I think that a lot of people who
enjoy access to certain areas now to go
hunting to,
to like hunt for themselves and their
family that the minute you made it be
that those deer had a dollar value
attached to them,
there'll be a lot less opportunity for
people who choose to hunt to feed
themselves because it will all of a
sudden be like,
why would I let you come in or allow you
to come in and use a resource when I'm
just going to do my best now to collect
it up and sell it.
Yeah.
And so again,
for aesthetic reasons,
for what it would mean for hunters,
for our,
our perception of our relationship with
our resources that I'm extremely
uncomfortable with the ice cube.
It's an idea that keeps popping up
because we have in some areas,
um,
and I,
and I usually,
I hate to say that I hate top of ours.
Too many deer.
There's too much this,
too much debt because like by WHO's
measurement.
But in some areas we really do,
especially when you start getting into
the,
to issues like lyme disease prevalence
and ticks.
And starvation and then just the
possibility of other disease outbreaks
and the spread of certain wildlife
diseases.
There's some areas that like by any
reasonable measurement.
We have too many deer.
Yeah.
Um,
well look,
it's already 1:00.
Oh,
how crazy is that?
Time flies in this room.
Your podcast is awesome.
It really is.
I'm glad to talk to you to doing it.
I owe it all to you and I.
and every chance I get,
I point to it.
I appreciate it.
I really do appreciate that you do it
because I think it's,
it's my favorite podcast to recommend to
people that want,
if I want them to get an understanding
of hunting without even watching it.
Just listening to you talk about because
he has.
He have so many guests on where he might
not even be talking about hunting.
You might be talking about biology,
might be talking about history.
You know,
it's a,
it's just a great podcast and you're a
great guy for the job.
You,
you play a very important part out
there.
I really,
really believe that.
Thank you.
I appreciate it and I'm glad you talked
me to doing it has been a in terms of
all the things I do,
the TV writing is the thing that I enjoy
doing it the,
it was a lot of things I enjoy having
done it more.
Right.
But the thing that I enjoy actually
doing it,
I'm deciding like a smile on my face
doing it.
What year is such a great
talker?
I mean,
remember the first time you did my
podcast even before mediator,
when you were just coming off of the
wild.
Within.
What is it?
Is that what it's called?
Yeah,
and I remember thinking,
why does this guy have a fucking
podcast?
And this is how many years ago,
seven years ago,
something like that.
Do you know the first time I ever heard
the word podcast?
This is good.
This is embarrassing.
The first time I ever heard the word
podcast was Helen Cho telling me that I
should go on Joe Rogan's podcast and I
didn't know what it meant.
That's how early you were into this
shit,
into this shit before I ever heard the
word.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Um,
I want,
I can,
I kind of doubled back around and plug
my book again.
Yeah,
please do.
Okay.
So it's called the meat eater,
fishing game,
cookbook,
recipes and techniques for every hunter
and Angler.
Got a picture of that,
Jamie,
a Bam.
There it is.
I say one last quick thing about it.
It releases right now,
releases this week on November 20,
but it's available for preorder
everywhere and it's um,
broken into a bunch of chapters where it
has big game,
small game like rabbits,
hares,
squirrels,
upland birds,
waterfowl,
fresh water or salt water,
fish,
Shell,
fish and crustaceans,
reptiles and amphibians.
So all your bullfrog stuff is in there
and you want to talk about a species.
It's spreading all across the country.
Bull 60.
Really?
Yeah,
I've hunted a lot of bullfrogs and
places where they're very unwelcome.
What do you hunt them with?
Um,
a variety of ways.
Most of your frog Gig,
I don't care where you live,
like there's a lot of people that live
in a city.
Like,
dude,
I'd love to go out and get some wild
game.
I can't read the elk.
I,
how do I do that?
You could be out gigging frogs at night,
no one would even know
frog gigging crayfish grab and we talked
about all this kind of stuff in the book
so it explains everything from how to
like break down and process and freeze
stuff.
And then for everything there are many
recipes and the recipes walk you through
how to use the entire thing.
So are you from for refer your white
tail deer.
Everything from the tongue to the rear
shank,
how like specific recipes on how to do
it.
And also,
um,
just general best practices and
guidelines around how to handle the
ingredients and then all the stuff
around all the substitutions.
So there's no such thing as an elkhart
recipe.
Riots like how to like handle game
hearts,
whether it's meal deer,
white tail,
whatever,
like how to approach a heart and a in a,
in an attitude toward wild game that is
not,
that's cut specific.
Not Species specific.
And with fish too,
like I don't,
I'm not with the idea of those is a
walleye recipe here.
This is a bluegill recipe,
but how to handle like varieties of
fresh water,
fish and like what kind of,
what kind of recipes you can use that
are interchangeable depending on where
you live and what you use and all
includes all that and the real pretty
pictures.
Beautiful.
You can see Yonis Patellas how to do the
tail skinning Methadone Squirrel.
And I don't care where you live.
You damn sure.
Live near squirrels.
People.
Very uncomfortable.
Squirrel eaten,
not me.
Oh,
and you know in the end,
the guy that got the disease means girl
brains.
Yeah.
Nothing to do with scroll brains.
Oh No.
The article I sent you.
Yeah.
What,
what did he.
Everybody sent me that article.
Yeah.
There's,
there's no demonstrable correlations.
Like 30 peep,
30 Americans a year,
you know,
wind up with that form of crumps felt 30
Americans wind up with.
It just happens to be this dude's
sometime in his past.
It's in some sort of.
It's a are prion disease and it's the
same thing Hamza people,
but,
but it was the correlation between his
diet and what happened to him was
implied.
Implied put possible.
If you go read up on it,
it now seems like people are really
saying like,
there's no,
there's no obvious relationship here.
No obvious relationship between eating
squirrel brains and getting a prion
disease.
Yeah.
There's plenty of people that get the
same thing that haven't been eating
squirrel brains.
Right.
So just,
they were just looking at the unusual
aspects of his diet and pointing to
that.
And it's not that scientific.
Yeah.
And the,
the article got a lot more love when it
was at some squirrel hundred died from
eating squirrel brains than it did when
the later subsequent pieces came out.
Wherever it is like,
whoa.
Yeah,
we don't really like girls are cute.
Yeah.
I ate some squirrel with you.
Just the thing,
you've very good.
There's not a person in the world.
You know what we have in the,
in the cookbook is we have um,
how to do buffalo,
buffalo wings,
hot wings,
how to do hot legs with squirrels were
unit the Arni.
Really?
Yeah.
So it's just like you making rules on
shooting squirrels.
Um,
they vary state by state.
Yeah.
So if,
if you're in New York,
you know,
you have a season,
um,
you know,
squirrel season in most states,
so it's either,
it's either one or the other way,
either there's a season in a bag limit
or the treated as a non game species.
So here in California there's a squirrel
season.
It was a bag of,
I think it's for a day for four
squirrels a day.
When's the season?
You know,
seasons usually run from sometime in
August,
in September into winter,
into January,
February.
So where I grew up September 15th,
September eighth to January,
27th.
Archery.
Falconry only Jesus crest.
So archery and foul,
foul Kinnari.
So August four for archery and falconry.
Falconry falcons.
Then you got to go to the tree squirrels
zone map,
right?
But in your estate Jack rabbits are
open.
For instance,
your State Jack Rabbits are managed as
non gaming.
There's no bag limit in open year round
snow,
like a cottontails.
No issues have different management and
a lot of states pine squirrels are red
squirrels,
which aren't commonly hunted,
but they're more regarded as like things
that get into people's houses,
but they're not 100 for me,
they'd be listed as a non game species,
but Fox girls and gray squirrels,
v as game species.
So in New York,
I think the bag limit when I was living
there was six per day,
a possession limit of two bag limits.
Did you shoot any squirrels in Brooklyn
and need them?
No.
No,
when I caught some there and ate them,
but I would hunt out of the city at my
buddy's farm and some other places.
So where I was born in Michigan,
the squirrel season was September 15th
and it ran into a van to January five
squirrels a day.
Possession limit of two bag limits.
The state I live in now treat squirrels
as non game species.
So there's no close season,
no bag limit because there's not really
a,
there's not a,
they're not widely distributed and
they're not commonly haunted.
All right.
But uh,
yeah,
most places they have them and they're
managed.
And you go out and buy a small game
license for 12 bucks or whatever.
Get your hunter safety,
get yourself a 22 or a or a shotgun.
And you can become a squirrel man or a
squirrel lady like you buddy.
Kevin Murphy,
one of my favorite guys on your podcast.
He's a squirrel man.
This guy blows a horn in the woods
before every hunt to alert the animals
that he's coming.
Yeah.
You blow.
He carries a cow horn around the,
I think um,
it's in,
uh,
a show far,
right?
Is that right?
For.
And when you blow the Shofar and like a
Jewish synagogue,
is that what it is?
Thanks.
Called a chauffeur.
Like you've blown the rams.
They below a Ram's horn.
It's not,
it's not a cow,
a cow harm.
It's ran,
you know,
the end of um,
in the end have no country for old men.
Yeah.
Have we talked about this before?
He talks about his father riding out
ahead of him or the Horn of fire
in the end when you get,
he relates the dream.
It's in the book and it's in the movie
for the Tommy Lee Jones characters
describing a dream in which they're
riding through a snow storm and his
father rides ahead with a Horn of fire.
And I was wondering how many people
heard that and had no idea what he was
talking about.
But what a common practice used to be as
you take a horn buffalo horn,
cow horn.
And it's hollow because,
um,
it grows off of protrusion of the skull
called the horn core.
And you pop the horn off and it's
hollow.
And what people will do is when you left
your campfire in the morning,
you would fill that horn with embers and
cap it,
but there'd be a little pinhole in it
just to let a little bit of air and air
so it could continue to smolder.
And you carry that Horn all day full of
embers.
And at night to start a new fire,
you would dump the horn out and rekindle
your fire.
So when he talks about his father riding
out ahead of them with a Horn of fire,
what that's meant to say is that he knew
his father will be waiting out ahead of
with
a fire burning.
Whoa.
Yeah.
But Kevin Murray just blows it.
Let squirrels.
Noise worries.
Thanks for coming,
man.
Always good to talk to you.
We keep saying we've got to organize
another hunt.
We have to give the love.
You have to do something.
Call Brian Cowen.
I talked to him recently.
We'll make it happen.
He's one of the phone.
Your guys on Instagram,
man.
He's one of the funniest guys alive.
Bye everybody.